Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Bist du eigentlich relevant.
Bis Sonntag noch.
Netzpolitik, die äh.
Neunundachtzigste.
Die neunundachtzigste Ausgabe, so ist es. Und die erste äh im Gloriosenja der äh der Revanche zwanzig vierzehn,
Das Jahr in dem wir zurück schlugen. Na ja, man muss ja mal auch ab und zu mal eine Prophezeiung fallen lassen.
Das Internet schlägt zurück.
Genau. Der äh ja, der Betrieb wird also jetzt wieder hier äh aufgenommen in der Mittebene und.
Genau einen Monat ist es her, die letzte Sendung.
Ja, also ähm ich habe so den Eindruck, es ist doch einiges passiert, aber bevor wir darauf eingehen, sagen wir erstmal äh hallo hier zu unserem dritten Mitspieler in der Runde, nämlich äh Thomas.
Guten Morgen.
Thomas Lunninger, genau, live aus Wien hier äh dazugeschaltet, wie es unsere Art ist, unser österreichischer Kost Korrespondent. Ja und wir haben alle was gemeinsam. Wir haben's alle nicht verpasst, wir waren alle dabei,
mittendrin.
Beim 30C3.
30C3. Wir waren dabei und äh wir können euch sagen,
alter Schwede.
Große Eier wurden gelegt.
Also, wenn das mal nicht fett war, dann weiß ich echt nicht mehr, was überhaupt fett sein soll. Das war wirklich, also ich bin immer noch total,
beeindruckt,
Auf so vielen Ebenen total beeindruckt. Das war einfach so viel, dass das kriegte man irgendwie alles mental gar nicht mehr so richtig verarbeitet. Wie geht's euch da?
Ja, ich hab's auch mental nicht verarbeitet bekommen. Ich bin ja dann nur noch als als Zombie rumgerannt ohne ohne Schlaf und äh.
Ganz normaler.
Ja, es, es war ähm ein, also es war wirklich irgendwie es war, alle wollten halt richtig auf die Kacke hauen und haben das auch gemacht. Jeder,
einzelne Gruppe, die da war mit ihrem mit ihrem Essen, jeder einzelne Engel, der irgendwie mitgemacht hat, ähm natürlich auch die Orga,
die da äh Sachen möglich gemacht hat, äh mit denen man echt kaum gerechnet hat. Also ich denke, dem glaube so die die größte Überraschung, was jetzt die Örtlichkeiten anging, war ja dann doch die neue Lounge, also die Partylocation.
Ja, also der Name launcht traf eigentlich gar nicht so richtig zu. Das war einfach ein Club. Ich hätte das den Club genannt.
Ja, das könnte man auch äh also das hätte man so jetzt auch gut als Club weiter betreiben können.
Genau, zumal ja Launches gab's ja dann zusätzlich auch noch eine Menge, die sehr wohl äh diesen Namen verdient haben.
Ne, also oben in der obersten Etage zum Beispiel da hinten, wo Falk und Moda noch was gemacht haben und überall lief Musik, war Kunst, es war irre. Wie ist mit dir, Thomas?
Ähm begeistert. Das war mein fünfter Kongress und bis jetzt sind sie alle immer besser geworden.
Es war ein riesiges Familientreffen. Es ist immer wieder faszinierend, dass wirklich alle interessanten, spannenden Leute, die so irgendwie in Europa oder auf der Welt gibt
dort auch hinkommen
und ja, es ist gut, dass man meistens danach sowieso immer eine Woche lang krank ist und zu Hause herumliegt, dann kann man irgendwie ein bisschen noch verarbeiten, was da alles passiert.
Ja. Das machen auch so einige, glaube ich, danach krank rumliegen. Ja und groß ist sie geworden, die Familie. Viel Nachwuchs,
Also die Leute strömten auf diese Veranstaltung wie nix Gutes
Man hatte das Gefühl, dass wir jetzt irgendwie diese unglaublich viel größere Location, die sind nach zwei Jahren auch schon wieder langsam in ihre Grenzen spielen. Ganz soweit war's jetzt noch nicht
Es war voll, aber die äh die Räume haben das schon noch alles irgendwie geschluckt. Aber man musste halt auch selber schon schlucken
äh ob der schieren Massen, die sich dort zusammenfanden. Und es gab halt wieder das, was wir eigentlich dachten, dass wir es jetzt auf ein paar Jahre nicht mehr haben würden, nämlich überfüllte Vortragsseele äh und das, obwohl da irgendwie dreitausend und tausendfünfhundert und ich weiß gar nicht, wie groß war dieser,
G-Saal, auch so, glaube ich, so tausend, tausendfünfhundert so in der Größenordnung da reinpassen. Ja, also auf jeden Fall,
jeder einzelne Saal war größer als der größte Saal im BCC.
Äh das sind sowieso, also wie war das denn? Mal von den, die Personen, die in Saal eins passen, sind die Gesamtanzahl, die wir im BCC haben konnten,
ganz hinten, ja? Also der nur dieser Raum, der hatte die Grundfläche des BCC.
Ja ja.
In Zahlen ist das und das war ja wirklich nur so, das war jetzt so die hinterste Kammer, wo halt dann noch äh Semis waren, ja, das war einfach mal die Grundfläche des BCC.
Ja, wobei die Grundfläche sich dann schon auf drei Etagen nochmal äh verteilt, aber.
Aber Grundfläche.
Grundfläche äh ja ja und Etagen gab's ja da auch äh noch und nöcher, also das CCH ist mittlerweile wirklich, muss ich sagen, perfekt für den Bedarf dieser Veranstaltung, die sich wahrscheinlich mittlerweile locker größte Konferenz Europas,
schimpfen darf.
Ich weiß nicht, was da was man da vergleichen kann. Der spannende Teil äh ist wie viel also,
Das ist natürlich schon jetzt auch ein ein sehr, sehr großes Wachstum, ne. Es hat irgendwie, klar, das kann man einmal darauf äh atribuieren, dass das ist irgendwie der Dreißigste ist, wo dann auch,
alle hinwollen, die vielleicht auch früher mal vielleicht alle drei Jahre mal gesagt haben, okay, dann lasse ich mal einen aus oder so. Ähm.
Vom letzten.
Nachher vom letzten. Dann natürlich die politischen Geschehnisse
und ähm so diese gesamte Mischung hat da natürlich echt ein äh ein riesen Haufen äh Menschen hingezogen, wie er dann in der Abschluss
Veranstaltung auch.
Oh ja, Overnights Haus, wobei ich glaube THS war nicht ganz memefest an der Stelle.
Da hat er hat er äh Schwäche gezeigt. Da hatte er eine offene Flanke gezeigt, äh das wem kannte er nicht?
Ja. Mhm.
Ähm aber,
Ich bin gespannt, wie sich das, wie man jetzt, also vom, vom Vortragsprogramm kann man jetzt schon sagen, ähm wir haben nicht die Qualität der äh Veranstaltung irgendwie,
lassen so. Also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie zu einer Kirmes geworden, nur weil ein paar tausend Leute mehr dahin gekommen sind,
Ganz im Gegenteil, das Programm war, ja okay, ich ich schaffe hier so viel über das Programm loben. Ähm
Aber das Programm war, denke ich, schon sehr, sehr gut ausgewählt, auch in den anderen Tracks. Und ähm man sieht aber jetzt natürlich, dass äh das Feedback, was also letztes Jahr war häufiger das Feedback der Talk war nicht technisch genug,
und äh dieses Jahr gibt es dann das Feedback äh der Talk war zu technisch. Ähm.
Hast du aber auch immer beides, je nachdem.
Hast du natürlich immer aber du hast natürlich dann auch so Fachleute die dann zu zum Vortrag von Andreas gehen ja,
und dann im Feedback schreiben, ey, ein bisschen zu technisch. Ja und Andreas.
Und Andreas hat da irgendwie so äh sich mit äh mit äh ähm ja Buffer Overflows und,
sonstigen Problemen in der C-Programmierung auseinandergesetzt. Und da halt das also ich ich denke, dass also,
Wenn er sagt, schon irgendwie so äh der dann geh halt nicht rein, wenn dir das zu technisch ist. So, dann geh halt derzeit in die Lounge, da ist weniger Technik und.
Die sind alle reingegangen, weil sie danach ja dann äh den Green Wolt sehen wollten,
Ja, also man kann mit diesem Kongress locker drei, vier, fünf oder sechs Podcasts noch äh füllen. Das da war einfach
so viel zu holen, das äh wird uns hier, glaube ich, auch noch lange beschäftigen. Die Frage ist,
Gehen wir jetzt nochmal auf irgendwas gezielt ein, also was hat dich denn am meisten überrascht? Das war so meine Lieblingsfrage äh auf dem Kongress immer.
Überrascht.
Na was hat dich am meisten überrascht? Oder was hat dich überhaupt überrascht?
Das ist jetzt schwierig, weil ich, weil ich ja wirklich kaum Überraschungen noch hatte, als ich hingekommen bin.
Deswegen frage ich ja.
Ähm insofern war das dann das hat mich am meisten überrascht.
Thomas, hast du da eine Antwort drauf?
Ich kann's eigentlich nur so ein bissel auf die allgemeine Stimmung beziehen, weil vom Programm her und den Leuten sind die Erwartungen zu, so hoch und so chaotisch, dass dass da keine Überraschung dabei ist, aber es war extrem harmonisch, das hat mich überrascht.
Also es war wirklich so, da findet irgendwie eine sehr diverse Gruppe von Menschen zusammen, ähm die alle eigentlich nur
gewisses Interesse eint, aber nicht das Selbe, sondern einfach nur so ungefähr vielleicht eine Art auf die Welt zuzugehen oder das, womit man sich in den letzten Jahr irgendwie beschäftigt hat. Und das reicht aber umso äh auch in der Größenordnung eine gute Grundstimmung,
zu erreichen und auch zu halten über die ganzen Tage der Veranstaltung,
Also äh so gut wie gar keine Streitereien oder irgendwelche Drama, sondern,
dass das in der Größenordnung noch so harmonisch ablaufen kann, das hat mich überrascht.
Ich habe das mal mit äh mit Rüdig. Rüdiger Weiß, der da auch einen Vortrag gehalten hat, so durchgerechnet. Ähm wenn man mal
Ausrechnet wie viel Personen, wie für wie viele Tage, wie viele Mannstunden das sind und wie viele Personen auf einen, ja gut, die Quadratperson pro Quadratmeter ist in dem Riesending immer noch nicht so besonders hoch, diese diese Dichte.
Aber wenn man jetzt einfach mal nur die Mannstunden nimmt, dann müsste es da eigentlich rein statistisch gebrochene Arme, gebrochene Beine, Schlägereien, Diebstahl und so weiter gehen. Ähm,
Und das gab's alles nicht. Ähm zumindest es wär's nicht zu Ohren gekommen. Es gab also Diebstahl gab's allerdings nicht aus dem aus den ähm.
Unter den Teilnehmern.
Teilnehmern. Ähm also es gab äh gab Diebstahl, aber eben von nicht Teilnehmern,
Ähm das ist, denke ich, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist, steht, es steht in, steht in keiner, äh keiner Relation.
Das ist eine schöne Rechnung und was mich, was mich am meisten überrascht hat, äh ist der äh,
kleine Offenbarung am Ende der Veranstaltung. Da gab's nämlich irgendwie nur vier oder sechs Eingeweihte, dass auf dem Kongress selber äh Schauspieler rumgerannt sind und versucht sich als Recruiter ausgegeben haben
um äh Besucher des Kongresses zu äh rekrutieren für Security Firmen. Und da auch dann am Ende eine ähm,
so eine Bullshit-Bingo-Rede gehalten wurde von einem vorgeblichen Investor und ähm.
Genau einem Sponsor der Veranstaltung,
Genau. Und äh jetzt ist natürlich der,
Der interessante Teil dabei ist, dass also was vielleicht nicht jedem klar ist, das ist natürlich ein sehr offener äh ähm,
winkt nach Holland, äh wo beim Camp eben diese große äh Sponsoring-Debatte war
und äh in die USA, wo dann bei der Blackhead äh der Kiew Alexander da irgendwie sein äh seine seine Rede halten darf. Ähm und da das so
selbstbewusst und so humorvoll anzugehen und zu sagen, ja guck mal hier, was wir hier wuppen können mit tausenden von Freiwilligen. Und ähm,
Ist doch echt mal eine eine äh eine feine Sache. Also das das war sehr überraschend, dass also ich habe dann auch ziemlich,
Überrascht geschaut, als dann eben wie gesagt wurde, ja jetzt darf der Sponsor auf die Bühne äh weil ich natürlich wusste, dass es keinen gibt, aber dachte, wer weiß,
gibt's ja doch alt.
Wobei man auch gleich korrigieren muss, der ist meinte ja dann irgendwie, wir werden ja nie ohne Sponsoren ausgekommen. Das ist insofern nur eingeschränkt richtig, als dass es natürlich sehr wohl.
Materialsponsoren.
Materialsponsoren, Netzsponsoren et cetera gab, das war auch in diesem Jahr nicht anders und die sind natürlich auch äh gewürdigt worden, aber das äh findet halt nicht auf einer Abschluss- oder Öffnungsveranstaltung statt
sondern in diesem Infrastruktur Review Talk, den man sich auch aus vielen anderen Gründen mal anschauen sollte. Ähm aber,
das also es es handelt sich hier um eine Veranstaltung, die einfach zu äh äh,
in ihrer gesamten Organisation und Finanzierung und so weiter selbst getragen wird. Mit der einzigen Ausnahme von Netz. Ja und äh,
Das sind alles aber auch Sponsor Deals
wir würden uns da niemals jetzt mit jemandem zusammentun, der halt darauf besteht, jetzt hier irgendwie als Goldsponsor auf jedem Flyer gedruckt zu sein und so weiter, wie das halt einfach der Standard ist, auf allen anderen Veranstaltungen. Man darf da, glaube ich, auch nicht zu arrogant sein
ja? Das zu erreichen ist nicht einfach und das ist sehr viel äh
Geschichte, dreißig Jahre CCC Geschichte eines sehr besonderen Vereins, äh für den einfach mittlerweile äh andere Regeln gelten und die jetzt niemand so mal eben aus dem Hut zaubern kann. Aber ich glaube, das Statement war jetzt,
Ich hab's weniger als ein Statement an an die Holländer gesehen.
Nein, nein, es war einfach nur ein äh, also es ist ein es ist nicht ein Statement an die Holländer, aber es ist natürlich klar, dass die Referenz hier da ist. Äh ist aber natürlich ein Statement, du das hat äh Thorsten ja auch klar gesagt, Andi Besucher selber.
An die Community, genau. Das, so würde ich das halt äh verstanden wissen wollen, dass man hier einfach sagt, äh A es geht auch anders. B, das ist auch wichtig. So und äh ich finde, das ist super rübergekommen und da haben auch irgendwie alle, sind auch alle mitgegangen, hat sich so den Eindruck.
Ja, das war doch super.
Und der Hack an sich war natürlich auch einfach mal ein unglaublicher Stand. Also da ist wirklich fünfhundert Befragungen, also Ansprachen durchgeführt werden konnten. Über vier Tage und das ist,
Fast niemandem aufgefallen ist er natürlich also der Honk wurde natürlich trotzdem misstrauisch so, also der hat schon also
Hongcase ist ja so einer unserer Security äh Erzengel, ja also der äh viel Erfahrung hat mit dieser Veranstaltung und dem ist dann schon äh äh,
Ja, der hat schon Lunte gerochen, weil ihm halt irgendwie so gesteckt wurde von anderen Leuten. So, ah, hier, guck mal, da sind Leute, die sprechen einen an und so. Also, was ich auch sehr cool finde, also aus weißt du, Leute, die angesprochen wurden, ja, haben dann gleich so ein bisschen,
äh Alarm geschlagen und sagt so, hier laufen unter Umständen Leute rum, die wollen wir hier nicht haben, ne. So und dann konnte man da,
letzten Moment noch einweihen und bremsen, dass er nicht die Schauspieler irgendwie ausm Haus wirft und ganze Sache noch.
Wir haben die, wie haben die Leute eigentlich reagiert? Also ist jemand auf die Angebote eingegangen, da er einen Job an.
Also die Zahlen waren ähm so, dass eigentlich von diesen fünfhundert Leuten, ich glaube, vierhundertfünfundneunzig haben einfach gesagt, verpiss dich.
Und von diesen letzten fünf und da bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob von diesen fünf.
Also ein paar haben dann irgendwie.
Also es sind, glaube ich, so maximal fünf. Ich weiß nicht, manchmal hieß es zwei, manchmal hieß es fünf, irgendwie so in diesem Range, die sind sozusagen darauf,
eingegangen, also in irgendeiner Form, ich weiß nicht, ob die dann eine Telefonnummer angerufen haben oder sonst irgendwie nochmal, einen zweiten Kontakt gehabt haben und dann kam es halt in Einzelfällen zu so einem Treffen im Hotel,
wo dann eben dieser Geschäftsführer noch dazukam zusätzlich zu diesem Recruiter, der diese Anbahnung gemacht hat und haben dann erstmal äh die betroffene Person äh dazu genötigt ein NDA zu unterschreiben,
Und in dem Moment, also es wurde ja kein Vertrag abgeschlossen, sondern
Und in dem Moment, wo dieses NBA unterschrieben wurde, in dem Moment, wo du das Ding schon aufgelöst, dieser äh Wisch äh zerrissen und äh Standpauke gehalten. Es gab aber auch einen Fall.
Die sind hingegangen und haben gesagt, ey, was ist das denn hier für eine dünnschattige Firma.
Und haben das mitgefilmt und wollten die auffliegen lassen, weil sie natürlich davon ausgegangen sind, dass es so euch euch zeige ich so. Dann waren da die Schauspieler erstmal in der Situation, dass die sich legitimieren mussten, also es
wirklich göttlich. Also man man hätte sich jetzt das nicht äh,
nicht besser vorstellen können, eine Reaktion und ja, das macht einen doch, also ich war vor allem ich war irgendwie extrem stolz auf diese Szene, äh das das war einfach eine Meisterleistung, dieser ganze Event auf allen Ebenen,
und äh pff also geträumt habe ich da bestimmt schon häufiger von, aber das ist mal so fett. Alles auf einmal zusammenkommen würde.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch erklären, äh nächstes Jahr, warum es nicht mehr so geil ist.
Ach.
Äh das war schon, also es war schon super. Es war ein Feuerwerk. Es hat, glaube ich, allen gut getan ähm und wir werden wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr dann wieder Ticket Lotterie haben, weil ähm wenn sich das jetzt rumspricht, wie es da war.
Steht zu befürchten, aber es ist,
es es ist schon noch ein bisschen Luft so, ne? Und nun ist auch nicht klar, ob man jetzt dieselben Anstrengungen wieder so äh übernehmen können. Es gab da eben auch viele äh Gruppen von außen, insbesondere, was diesen Klub da betrifft. Ja, wo, sagen wir mal, dem Club auch ein,
Geburtstagsgeschenk gemacht wurde durch die äh Initiative, die dort entwickelt wurde. Ja, ich sage nur, die Bar, ja, die da irgendwie in sieben Tagen,
ausm abgebrannten Dachstuhl zusammengezimmert wurde und außer als wäre so aus dem Katalog. Na ja, also wir verfangen uns jetzt hier in tausend Details und wir könnten ja noch ewig erzählen, aber eigentlich wollten wir ja,
auch mal ein bisschen das Geschehen wieder zusammenfegen, oder?
Genau, aber also wir empfehlen natürlich die alle, alle Videos zu schauen. Man kann sie runterladen und man kann sich, glaube ich, daran erfreuen und das das Medienecho Internationaler Art auf diese Veranstaltung war natürlich auch enorm.
Genau, wir werden jetzt hier kein detailliertes Vortragsreview machen, aber wir werden sicherlich da, wo unsere Themen äh das tangieren, auch immer mal wieder in den nächsten Wochen und auch heute nochmal auf den einen oder anderen Talk verweisen.
Genau, sollen wir anfangen?
Ja, ich würde sagen, wir legen jetzt mal los.
Ähm Thomas, womit möchtest du anfangen? Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder Netzneuität?
Mmh, tun, wie du willst, also ich hätte jetzt mich an die Reihenfolge im Pad gehalten, aber hm, dann machen wir mal Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ganz schnell. Ja.
Genau. Pedro Gruß Villa.
Genau. Das ist der Generalanwalt des Europäischen Gerichtshofs, der in dem Verfahren gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
und der Ackervorrat Österreich angestrebt haben, jetzt mal seinen Schlussantrag äh formuliert hat. Das ist noch kein Urteil, aber das ist sowas wie die Vorlage für das Urteil
Und ähm,
Ja, da da kommt dann nochmal ein Richtersenat, der sich diesen Schlussantrag ansch anschaut und nochmal entscheiden kann, ob das wirklich das Urteil ist oder nicht, aber ein vier von fünf Fällen machen die das auch. Also wir wissen jetzt so ungefähr, in welche Richtung das Verfahren gehen wird. Und,
Einschätzung, also das ist wirklich das europäische Höchstgericht an der Stelle,
Dann gibt's doch noch den IGMR, aber der Weg dahin ist wirklich ganz schwierig. Also dort wird entschieden, ob Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf EU-Ebene grundrechtskonform ist oder eben nicht.
Und ja, in diesem Schlussantrag, der, glaube ich, schon so am, am zwölften Dezember kam,
ähm haben wir in großen Teilen Recht bekommen. Das ist auch ein Grund zur Freude, also der der Schlussantrag sagt, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in ihrer derzeitigen Form grundrechtswidrig ist.
Und abgeschafft werden muss. Er eröffnet aber auch die Möglichkeit einer,
Tour und äh also er sagt so irgendwie so wie er das jetzt gemacht hat, geht das nicht. Aber prinzipiell ist es machbar
Also sehr ähnlich wie der Deutsche Verfassungsgericht soviel Karlsruhe, ähm das leider auch zu erwarten war, weil der Deutsche ist schon so irgendwie, der gilt zu den gehört zu den mutigsten Verfassungsgerichtshöfen der Welt,
Ja und wir erwarten irgendwie, dass endgültige Urteil dann im ersten, zweiten Quartal dieses Jahr zweitausendvierzehn,
Und dann werden wir wissen, in welche Richtung das gehen wird.
Also er sagt äh glaube ich im Detail, dass das Sammeln grundsätzlich ist, hält er für zulässig
aber das Missbrauchspotential ist zu hoch und er verlangt äh da irgendwie eine Wiederherstellung der Verhältnismäßigkeit, äh indem es konkrete Vorgaben zum behördlichen Datenzugriff geben soll und ähm eine geringere Speicherfrist Definition als äh bis zu zwei Jahre
Das heißt, er sagt, dürfen zu viele dran? Und,
Es wird zu lange gespeichert. Und dieser ein, dieser Eingriff ist zu groß, wenn man überlegt, welches Grundrecht da oder welche Grundrechte da eingeschränkt werden.
Genau, also ähm.
Aber er sagt also genau, was du gerade schon gesagt hast, die Grundidee greift er eben nicht an. Das wäre natürlich noch schöner gewesen, oder?
Ja
hätten wir uns auch gewünscht. Also das wäre ja auch ein wirklicher Sieg auf ganzer Linie gewesen, weil wenn Pauschale verdachtsunabhängige Datensammlungen wirklich unrechtswidrig sind, dann heißt das ja natürlich auch, was für
äh Swift für PNA, also für für die pauschale Speicherung von Bankdaten und von Fluggastdaten. Und da hätte man noch viel, viel mehr dann rauslesen können, aber so weit ist er leider nicht gegangen.
Und es ist ja auch jetzt noch keine finale Entscheidung des Gerichts, sondern es ist eine Vorlage.
Der Schlussantrag des Generalanwaltes, dem das Gericht in, ja.
In der Regel.
Fälle folgt.
Ja, dann bleiben ja noch zwanzig Prozent. So, also das ist, sagen wir mal, noch nicht komplett aus dem Ofen jetzt, ne? Aber es riecht gut und äh sieht gut aus. Und äh wann kommt die Entscheidung, was hattest du? Ähm.
Ja, also wir rechnen so irgendwie erstes, zweites Quartal. Ja.
Okay, also dauert noch ein bisschen. Naja.
Also im Moment steht, das heißt im Moment stehen die Zeichen wahrscheinlich, dass äh diese Richtlinie neu äh gestaltet werden muss.
Ja, man merkt das ja jetzt auch schon äh die Auswirkungen davon, hier unser neuer Justizminister, ähm,
hat ja auch schon äh nachdem wie wir berichteten, die große Koalition ja im Prinzip die Sprechung wieder äh schön äh ins Ziel gefasst hat
meinte er schon so, na ja, hm, irgendwie, das würde ja jetzt erstmal noch nicht so äh weiter betreiben, bis denn das hier nicht äh entschieden sei und es sähe ja danach aus, dass äh die Entscheidung hier in eine Richtung geht, die vielleicht dazu führt, dass es gar nicht umsetzbar ist in der aktuellen Form und dann bräuchte er ja auch nix zu tun. Also
Botschaft scheint schon auch ein wenig angekommen zu sein.
Das äh ist erstmal natürlich sehr, sehr gut. Und das muss ich sagen, das war wirklich mal eine Überraschung. Also das hat mich echt überrascht, dass dieser äh frisch gebackene Justizminister hingeht, äh die da groß irgendwie in ihrer GroKo reinschreiben. Wir machen jetzt hier Vorratsdatenspeicherung und der stellt sich jetzt als allererstes erstmal hin und sagt, ach hier übrigens
Nee, so das äh äh das erscheint mir hier unsinnig und äh die Argumente, die er da dafür vorträgt, äh sind natürlich ähm,
sinnvoll.
Bestimmt das ein oder andere Auge gerollt worden in der CSU-Fraktion.
Ja, die haben das Innenministerium war ja dann auch äh not im.
Ja, ein interessantes Detail dazu nochmal. Ähm wenn man sich mal wirklich anschaut, wie äh die Richter damals das argumentiert haben und wie auch äh jetzt dieses Urteil ist, ja? Ähm
Diese Richtlinie kommt ja von zweitausendsechs und ist als Maßnahme zur Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes gemacht worden. Also so äh wir wollen einen europäischen Markt und
wir haben da
Telkos und die speichern alle irgendwie und manche speichern noch nicht, deswegen Markt harmonisieren wir das. Das wurde nicht aus sicherheitspolizeiliche Maßnahme gemacht, deswegen fehlt da auch ähm jeder Grundrechtsschutz, also diese Abwägung zwischen äh Freiheit und Sicherheit,
wurde überhaupt nicht getroffen in dieser Richtlinie, sondern die hat man den Mitgliedsstaaten überlassen. Und das ist einer der Kernkritikpunkte des Europäischen Gerichtshofes an der Stelle,
und das wird auch ähm an die an die Kommission, die ja wieder eine neue Richtlinie machen muss. Äh einer dieser Aufgaben seien, die sie damit erfüllen müssen. Also, das wird nämlich konkret so ablaufen, dass der EuGH, wenn also jetzt diesem Schlussantrag
gehen wir mal davon aus, dass er dann sagen wird, okay, Vorratsdatenspeicherung gilt noch.
Monate oder Jahre, solange habt ihr Zeit, dieses Gesetz neu zu machen? Wenn nicht, dann fällt das einfach und ist außer Kraft
und für diese Reparatur kann er auch Auflagen machen. Das heißt, der kann eben sagen, niedrigerer Speicherdauer, es muss geregelt sein, in welchen Straftaten und wer überhaupt zugreifen kann darauf, auf Vorratsdaten und wann die wieder gelöscht werden müssen bei den Behörden. All diese Dinge.
Das ist natürlich ein Minenfeld für Deutschland, wenn wenn sie jetzt umsetzen würden und ein Gesetz machen, dass dann in ein, zwei Jahren noch in dieser Koalition wahrscheinlich ähm als grundrechtswidrig erklärt wird.
Spaßfakt ist auch, dass durch diese Entscheidung in allen Ländern, in denen es bis jetzt schon eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt, diese sofort mit hinfällig würde, weil sie ja dokumentiert gegen äh die Grundrechte verstößt und vom EuGH
in der Form nicht zulässig ist. Es sei denn, wir fänden jetzt ein Land, das,
Speicherung genau so ausgestaltet hat, dass sie mit der Definition des EuGH dann immer noch akzeptabel wäre. Das heißt
auch unter den, auch ja, also
ohne also die Richtlinie nicht so erfüllt, dass sie äh trotzdem dann noch unter dieser Schwelle bleibt. Das ist äh denke ich auch relativ unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, das würde ich auch meinen.
Wichtig ist noch, wir werden da wieder eine politische Debatte darüber haben. Also die EU kann nicht einfach Vorratsdatenspeicherung neu machen, ohne dass wir dagegen sein werden. Und das ist auch, was auf das man sich freuen kann.
Ja, wir führen die Debatten von zweitausendneun nochmal oder äh wann war das? Äh zweitausendsechs, zweitausendsechs.
Habe den Eindruck, die werden wir so schnell nicht loswerden, diese Debatte.
Nee.
Gut, ähm dann sind ja noch einen anderen äh Bereichen Dinge äh passiert, beziehungsweise stehen an. Äh Thema Netzneutralität,
Und äh da hast du ja auch zusammen mit Markus Beckedal einen äh Vortrag gehalten,
auf dem Kongress, auf dem wir dann in den Links verweisen werden, äh in welchem Saal wart ihr denn eigentlich? Seit zwei, ne? Und wie war das so?
Äh ja, es war mein erster Kongress-Talk. Ich.
Dann gleich so tausendfünfhundert Leute, ja?
Ja
War voll, ja?
Ähm war war nicht gesteckt voll, aber es es war gut besetzt.
Na ja.
Und ja, tun uns war äh der Vortrag war gut, äh den kann man sich auch anschauen
ähm ist eine Empfehlung, weil wir da am Anfang kehrt Markus eben Netzzentralität an sich das Grundprinzip und die deutsche Debatte und ich habe dann so den europäischen internationalen Teil gemacht, weil
das Thema brennt ja jetzt gerade wirklich an allen Ecken und Enden in USA, in Brasilien und eben auch in Europa wird ganz heftig darüber gestritten,
Und in Europa, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon mal erwähnt haben, ich glaube einmal habe ich schon gesagt, aber diese EU-Verordnung von Neli Cruise, die jetzt auf dem Tisch liegt, ist ja wirklich eine de facto Abschaffung der Netzneutralität,
Äh unter anderem, äh da stehen ja auch noch Netzsperren drinnen und ähm so wirklich es zwei Klasseninternet wird Pflicht auch im Backboard bei den Providern,
Also das ist ähm wirklich so in Sachen Netzwerk jetzt grade der Entfight. Also das ist der Boss-Kampf,
den wir jetzt in den nächsten zwei, drei Monaten zu führen haben, weil die EU will diese Verordnung wirklich noch in dieser Gesetzgebungsperiode vor der EU-Wahl im Mai zweitausendvierzehn durchboxen
Und das heißt, dass wir wirklich bis zum siebenundzwanzigsten Februar, wenn die Abstimmung im federführenden Ausschuss, dem itree Ausschuss stattfindet
massiv mobilisieren müssen, weil ansonsten haben wir die längste Zeit Netzvortralität gehabt in Europa.
Und äh dazu haben wir auch eine Kampagne gemacht. Safety Internet Punkt EU,
Äh das ist so irgendwie eine gemeinsame ein gemeinsamer Kraftakt von von, von und von Initiative für Netzfreiheit,
und wir versuchen da irgendwie über diese Verordnung aufzuklären, den Leuten überhaupt mal näher zu bringen, weil die meisten,
Bürger und auch die meisten Abgeordneten haben noch nie davon gehört. Nachdem das so ein extrem knapper Zeitplan ist, das wurde ja erst im September letztes Jahr vorgestellt,
und jetzt soll schon drüber abgestimmt werden, haben die wenigsten Leute überhaupt davon mitbekommen und auch die wenigsten Parlamentarier. Und jetzt geht's einfach drum, die Leute aufzuklären und,
Dazu haben wir auch auf dieser Webseite Safety Internet EU zu einer äh ruft einen Abgeordneten an Kampagne gemacht.
Da kann man äh ohne dass es irgendwas kostet, einfach seine Nummer angeben und dann ruft man einen Parlamentarier an und kann dem erklären, wie so Netzzentralität wichtig ist,
und äh Mails kann man auch dadrüber schicken, zig Argumente findet man, das ist gerade so irgendwie das Baby, in dem wir alle arbeiten in den nächsten zwei Monaten.
Ich dachte, die Neli Cruise wäre immer so die Internetfreiheitskämpferin gewesen.
Ja, das ist ganz lustig. Damit hat sie angefangen, als sie irgendwie ins Amt kam, ähm und sich zweitausendzehn so erster öffentliche Aussagen zur Netzautralität machte. Da haben wir alle große Hoffnungen bekommen, weil sie hat gemeint, ja für sie wäre das ein No-Go, wenn,
Provider aus kommerziellen Gründen diskriminiert,
sie hat sich aber leider um hundertachtzig Grad gedreht in den letzten Jahren und ist inzwischen zu einer Befürworterin von genau der Industrielinie geworden,
Und ähm scheint irgendwie aus den Augen verloren zu haben, was Netzzentralität als als,
Prinzip für einen Wert darstellt, für die Gesellschaft, für die Wirtschaft, für die Demokratie. Und äh ich glaube auch nicht nur, dass man sie daran erinnern wird, weil die Frau geht ja in ähm in Rente, also die wird nicht nochmal antreten, so wie es aussieht. Das heißt, die ist auch weg im Mai.
Die hinterlässt uns jetzt grade irgendwie ein Schlachtfeld und verabschiedet sich in ein paar Monaten. Und äh deswegen ist sie auch nicht mehr derjenige, diejenige, die man da überzeugen kann, sondern da geht's jetzt wirklich ums Parlament. Das ist gerade so unsere Hoffnung.
Das war doch auch die Idee in äh Gutenberg, denn da ist Internetfreiheitskämpfer eingestellt hat, oder?
Ganz genau, ja?
Wohl gut funktioniert.
Einen sehr interessanten äh äh Artikel von der Kirsten Fiedler auf Netzpolitik org, wo dann nämlich mal auf eine äh Anfrage so die,
Aktivitäten dieses Mannes gefunden wurden. Das waren sage und schreibe fünf ähm fünf Sachen hat er gemacht,
Wie ein, ein Treffen, ein Strategietreffen in Brüssel, eine Pressekonferenz in Brüssel, eine Konferenz in Stockholm, ein paar Unternehmen in Silicon Valley getroffen,
und dann nochmal äh irgendwie noch mal äh sich mit ein paar Leuten in Brüssel getroffen. Hat ja keine ähm
Reisekosten, äh keine, kein Honorar genommen, sondern nur für diese fünf Treffen. Äh Reisekosten im in der Höhe von knapp zwanzigtausend Euro,
generiert. Äh sehr schön.
Mann ist sein Geld auch wert, oder?
Ja, ich werden wir sehen. Also ähm na ja, also das fand ich äh fand ich sehr interessant. Das war ja äh zu befürchten,
Und das scheint sie offensichtlich in letzter Zeit von den falschen Leuten beraten
äh worden zu sein. Aber vielleicht kannst du nochmal im Detail nochmal ganz kurz sagen, du hast gesagt, sie wollen bis ins backbown hinein die das zwei Klassennetz äh definieren. Wie stelle ich mir das vor?
Ja, das ist eine ähm ganz spannende Sache. Ein Artikel neunzehn der Verorden findet sich was Neues, das sie da erfunden haben, das heißt Shure Service Quality. Und das ist eine Angebotspflicht für ISPs, Quality of Service Interconnects.
Anzubieten. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so irgendwie als äh Sony-Entertainment zu irgendeinem Provider gehe, auch einem kleinen und dem sage, so ich will jetzt hier äh mit dir und ähm das muss jetzt aber
super priorisiert sein mit niedriger Latenz da muss der mir mal ein Angebot stellen. Ähm wenn er das dann
wenn wenn das aus technischen Gründen nicht machen kann oder weil der Preis zu hoch ist, dann eskaliert das so auf die Regulierungsbehörde, aber am Anfang ist es mein ziemlich starker Hebel
Aller als Peace, äh Quality of Service in ihren Netzen etablieren müssen,
und das eben auch wirklich nach externen Verkaufen an Inhalte und Diensteanbieter.
Ähm und was mit diesem Prinzip verbunden ist, ist etwas, das wir schon von Telko Seite, von der Deutschen Telekom, aber auch von von Ethno, so dem europäischen Providerverbund kennen
Also von den ganzen wirklich hardcore Netzentralitätskritikern. Also dieses Prinzip Party Network Pace. Das heißt, ich schicke dir Daten
und ich schicke dir Geld und über das Prinzip wollen Sie eben etablieren, dass es nicht nur das Best-Efford-Internet gibt, sondern auch eine bezahlte Überholspur
und die eben halt auch wirklich Netzwerk. Das Problem ist ja, wenn ich als Provider heute Special als Services verkaufen will und ähm eigentlich aber nur normale Peerings habe zu meinen Kunden, vor allem auch
zu welchen Team, den ich vielleicht jetzt nicht direkt verbunden bin, sondern über zwei, drei Ecken erst
äh dann kann ich ja nicht wirklich diese Dienstequalität äh technisch nachweisen und glaubhaft machen. Äh über so eine Angebotspflicht
wird das auf einmal im gesamten Netz möglich, äh diesen Doppelboden einzuziehen und und diese bezahlte Überholspur zumindest im gesamten europäischen Netz zu etablieren. Also es ist nichts, was Neues, also theoretisch kann man all das schon mit Service Level Agreements heute schon machen,
Aber dass es wirklich Pflicht wird für alle, ist äh zumindestens unnötig und
dann es macht auch keinen Sinn, sagen auch die europäischen Regulierungsbehörden, dass man das eigentlich nicht bräuchte. Und ähm unserer Meinung nach ist es noch hochgradig gefährlich und und macht halt wirklich so auf Backboard-Ebene zwei Klassen-Internet zu Pflicht.
Also sorgt dafür, dass ich, wenn ich ein Netz, Netzneutralität, verletzendes Angebot machen möchte, auch,
das Recht bekomme, diese das auch von anderen Angeboten zu bekommen, dass ich das auch durch andere Netze hindurch machen kann,
verstehe ich das jetzt. Also ich habe irgendwie, mir ist noch ein anderer Anbieter im Weg und der macht irgendwie einen auf Netzneutralität, dann kann ich mit dieser Verordnung jetzt sagen, nee
Ich verspreche meinen Kunden, dass du dass das bevorzuge bevorzugt behandelt wird und ich möchte von dir ein Preisangebot haben, dass ich das auch umsetzen kann so.
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Also.
Unglaublich.
Und das ist halt also es ist halt einfach so das letzte Stück im Puzzle. Ähm nach
Services schon so definiert haben, dass damit alles geht, also wirklich von Spotify Deal bis hin zu Facebook only, auf, auf, auf zum Beispiel Wertkarten, Internettarifen
Ähm das ist also auf der auf der Kundenebene haben sie schon irgendwie die Schleusentore soweit aufgemacht, wie es nur geht. Und ähm dann tun sie halt eben dasselbe auch nochmal ähm und zwischen den ISPs im Interconnect.
Frage. Ähm es gibt doch so diese klassischen Netzneutralität, Verletzenden äh Dinge in, ich glaube, da war jetzt wieder ein Beispiel in Afrika, wo ein Anbieter gesagt hat, okay,
Ähm wir geben allen Nutzern schon mal gratis Zugriff auf die Wikipedia. Ähm,
Wo man natürlich jetzt sagen würde, so boah, ne, toll, wenn man, wenn man sich überlegt, was sie was also,
Zumindest die, die Länder in Afrika, die ich äh besucht habe, da wird äh sehr viel Geld äh sehr signifikanter Teil des Einkommens an äh für Telefon und solche Sachen ausgegeben. Wenn man den Leuten sagt, Mensch, hier gratis Wikipedia, das wäre doch echt so ein ein Traum der Menschheit, der da in Erfüllung
geht.
Ja, das äh
ist ein spannendes Thema, diese ganzen Wikipedia, Zero und Facebook Zero Angebote, wie sie heißen, wo das Datenvolumen einfach nicht abgerechnet wird, wenn wenn Facebook oder Wikipedia einen Deal mit meinem Eisbier haben. Ähm,
Wikipedia kann man das so im Global South noch argumentieren, finde ich, dass man sagt, äh das macht an der Stelle Sinn
jetzt unter dem Duktus einer einer Entwicklungshilfemaßnahme
Ähm in entwickelten Ländern, die einen funktionierenden Internetmarkt haben, wo sich doch ein Großteil der Bevölkerung ähm adäquaten Internetzugang leisten kann. Da
und das wird mehr oder weniger verunmöglicht indem die solche Dienst
Dienst äh Deals abschließen mit ähm den ISPs, in denen sie einfach ihre Marktmacht zementieren, also.
Zumal ja
die die Idee für den für den Anbieter selber auch ist. Ach super, lasst die Nutzer mal schön auf Wikipedia gehen, da unter jedem Artikel sind fünfzig Links, die ins richtige Internet führen äh und mit denen ich dann die paar Bites, die sie sich aus der Wikipedia geholt haben, auch sehr schnell wieder äh gegenfinanziert bekommen
bekommen. Also ich denke, das sind eigentlich immer so Anfütterangebote. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das noch aktiv ist, aber wir haben ja auch schon vor längerer Zeit davon berichtet, das E-Plus irgendwie
so ein Punkt Facebook oder so was,
solche Angebote macht. Das sind natürlich auch Anfütterangebote einfach nur, die da gemacht werden und gegenüber der,
Deswegen stelle ich dir die Frage auch gegenüber der, sage ich mal, den den ähm,
ja, Bürgerrechtlern oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag, ähm
besonders äh perfide Strategien, sowas zu machen, ne. So also quasi so ja willst du denn, dass die
den Menschen in Afrika die Bildung verwehrt wird, so nur du mit deinem mit deiner komischen kommunistischen Ansicht über über das Internet so, ne?
Ist schon echt per, das ist schon perfide. Da wird ja alles äh gezogen.
Ja, also ich finde auch eigentlich würde ich mir zumindest erhoffen, wenn nicht erwarten, von von Wiki Media
Deutschland, Österreich, Europa, dass man
so ehrlich ist und an der Stelle auf Wikipedia Zero verzichtet und einfach sagt, ja, wir erkennen an,
was zum Erfolg der Wikipedia geführt hat. Die Bedingungen, die dieses Projekt überhaupt möglich gemacht haben, waren Netzneutralität und deswegen sind wir in entwickelten Ländern für Netzneutralität und ähm wollen deswegen dieses Prinzip auch nicht selbst unterwandern und unter Gegenseite
äh sehr gefährliche Argumente geben, indem wir hier solche Subventionierten Deals abschließen. Das wäre meiner Meinung nach die politisch richtige Haltung
der Wiki Media an der Stelle, vor allem eben grade auf EU-Ebene im Hinblick auf die Diskussion um die Verordnung.
Na gut, ich meine Wikimedia zahlt ja sicherlich kein Geld dafür für solche Sachen, ja, sondern das ist dann an der Stelle einfach eine Entscheidung des Providers, da hat Wiki Media eigentlich gar keinen Einfluss.
Also ich glaube schon, dass Dieter Diehls abschließen. Natürlich, der Provider könnte das äh im Rahmen seiner AGBs ohne Netzneutralität
machen, dass er einfach Dienste davon ausnimmt, von der Volumensberechnung, aber
Ähm ich glaube schon, also da gibt's auf jeden Fall ähm Stimmen in Wikipedia, die dieses Wikipedia Zero als sehr prestigeträchtig ansehen und und und eben nicht kritisch hinterfragen.
Verstehe.
Stimmen in der Wikipedia.
Gut, ähm ich denke.
Schönsten.
Zur Netzneutralität ist jetzt erstmal alles gesagt, oder?
Äh ja, wie gesagt, safe die Internet EU, das ist der Anlaufpunkt, wo ähm vielleicht mal wirklich alle, die den Podcast hören, hinschauen sollten, die Seite wird ständig noch geupdatet, ist auch alles auf Gitter
ähm wenn man da irgendwie Verbesserungsvorschläge hat oder vielleicht auch noch ein paar Übersetzungen machen will,
versuchen, das Projekt in möglichst viele Sprachen zu übersetzen, haben gerade Deutsch und Englisch, Französisch und Polnisch ist auf dem Weg und äh wer da was machen will, der soll sich bitte bei mir melden oder einfach auf Githup gehen, wir verlinken das
und ja, echt so irgendwie mit Abgeordneten zu sprechen und die anzurufen, ist auch eine wirklich empfehlenswerte Erfahrung, was so irgendwie ähm das demokratische Grundverständnis angeht, weil gerade auf europäischer Ebene
hören die einem auch wirklich zu,
Ähm das das ist teilweise erschreckend, aber die eigenen Argumente können da wirklich einen Unterschied machen und das gibt ein sehr gutes Gefühl an der Stelle, die
Themen, die einem selber wichtig sind, auch an der Stelle anzubringen, wo die Entscheidung getroffen wird. Das ist das ist ein Vorteil vom Europaparlament.
Gerade viele, viele deutsche Abgeordneten in dem federführenden Ausschuss. Deswegen wär's auch wirklich gut, wenn wir da Schützenhilfe bekämen aus Deutschland.
Gut, also alle Hörer an die Browser klicken und durchlesen und.
Telefonieren und.
Genau.
Ist sowieso mal eigentlich, sollte man sowieso öfter machen. Das machen die Resonanz auf solche äh äh kontaktier deinen Abgeordneten, äh Aktion ist teilweise echt erschreckend,
Gering, wenn man sich überlegt, was das eigentlich für eine Selbstverständlichkeit sein sollte und wie wie schön das wie schön man das machen kann. Es sind, glaube ich, in USA auch viel verbreiteter, dass man als Millionär dann einfach auch mal seinen Senator äh besucht, ja?
Und wir können, wir haben noch die Gelegenheit, das äh zu machen, obwohl wir äh gar keine Millionäre sind.
Ja, die Millionäre, die weiß nicht, also wenn die Entscheidung nicht in die richtige Richtung gehen, dann.
Das soll nicht heißen, dass Millionäre da jetzt nicht anrufen dürfen, ne.
Sie kanzeln ihre Schecks, die rufen da nicht an.
Äh nichts gegen Millionäre, einige meiner besten.
Genau, also stellt alle eure Zahlungen ein, ja.
Okay, ähm wir haben eine Meldung aus Österreich, Thomas.
Genau. Äh letztes kleines Thema, das ich noch irgendwie erwähnt haben will, ist, dass äh in Österreich jetzt ähm ja die elektronische Gesundheitsakte, kurz LGA
startet und dass äh alle Menschen, die in Österreich gesundheitsversichert sind, die Möglichkeit haben,
dann zu machen ist wie's der Name sagt halt so die komplette Vernetzung von allen Gesundheitsdaten
Das heißt, da habe ich dann alle meine Laborbefunde drinnen
Überweisungen vom Arzt und und die Medikamente, die mir verschrieben wurden. Und äh ja, das Teil äh fangt jetzt gerade so an, anzulaufen und es ist so gebaut, dass man als normaler Mensch einfach sagen kann, nein, will ich nicht und dann schreibt man,
Brief oder meldet sich mit seiner Bürgerkarte ab und dann ist man nicht mehr dabei,
Ähm ich bin da nicht so tief drin, weil ich habe schon so viele Themen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall für alle Menschen, die irgendwie in Österreich äh leben, etwas, womit man sich beschäftigen sollte. Ich habe,
Ich bin zwar skeptisch, aber ich habe mir selber noch keine abschließende Meinung gebildet,
es gibt da jetzt aber gerade ein paar sehr spannende Ansätze von Leuten so Entscheidungslisten zu bauen mit Pro-Contra, Elga und äh und da gibt's auch ein Treffen am vierzehnten Jänner um achtzehn Uhr dreißig im Werkzeughall in Wien, dass ich erwähnen wollte. Ähm
ja
Also elektronische Gesundheitsakte klingt ähm nicht,
nicht schlau, wenn ich das, was ich sagen darf. Also äh also so aus äh,
Perspektive, wir machen mal hier bisschen Security oder so und das soll irgendwie ein Leben lang halten. Klingt äh elektronische Gesundheitsakte wie eine Idee, die noch vielen Menschen irgendwann leid tun wird.
Also bei Akte reden wir jetzt von einer zentralen Speicherung.
Das ist das Spannende, also es es passiert im Moment noch dezentral. Das ist die Daten bleiben bei den Ärzten oder Spitälern, wo sie jetzt schon liegen und jetzt auch schon zum Großteil digitalisiert sind
was Neues ist, äh so ein zentrales System, mit dem ich diese Daten abrufen kann. Ähm aber eben auch die Möglichkeit habe als Patient selber zu schauen, was sind meine Befunde der letzten zehn Jahre äh und auch zu sagen, so
Der Arzt darf jetzt aber nicht sehen, was der andere vor drei Jahren mir mal verschrieben hat und solche Sachen.
Ähm es ist irgendwie ein System mit einigen Graustufen natürlich, also in der derzeitigen IT-Sicherheitslage herzugehen und Gesundheitsdaten zu digitalisieren. Es an sich keine gute Idee.
Ähm aber ja, man muss halt irgendwie
beide Seiten da noch irgendwie betrachten, weil es ist die Daten sind schon digitalisiert und äh wir hatten auch erst in Österreich einen riesigen Skandal, wo Patientendaten verkauft wurden
an so amerikanische Gesundheitsdienste die, die dann weiter verkauft haben,
Also eigentlich gibt's in hohe Sensibilität in der Bevölkerung gerade und das ist halt so einer der Debatten, die es wert ist, beobachtet zu werden in Österreich.
Also ich würde ja jetzt nicht unterschreiben, dass es grundsätzlich eine schlechte Idee ist, Gesundheitsdaten und eigene Akten äh in digitaler Form äh vorzuhalten. Ja, die Frage ist eher
wird es gespeichert, wie wird es dort gesichert und wie ist eben der Zugriff da drauf? Also wer regelt sozusagen die Zugriffsbeschränkung? Liegt das komplett in meiner Hand?
Oder äh wie
und äh die Modelle sind da halt einfach nicht so, dass sie sich jetzt besonders viel Gedanken darüber machen, dass was weiß ich nur, wenn ich jetzt meine Karte mit meinen äh äh mit meinem persönlichen Chip da irgendwo mal äh durchwinke, dann darf der Arzt, vor dem ich jetzt gerade sitzen, darauf zugreifen
versus
es ist irgendwie online äh im schlimmsten Fall noch zentral gespeichert in einer Datenbank unverschlüsselt und jeder, der irgendwie halbwegs einen Login hat, kann im Prinzip alles runterladen.
Genauso sieht's aber doch am Ende dann aus.
Ja ja klar, aber das.
So ist doch eine Effizienzsteigerung für den Gesundheitsbetrieb äh zu erzielen.
Ja, ich ich wollte, ich wollte nur seine Aussage etwas ähm abfedern, weil ich glaube, man steht dann auch in der Diskussion jetzt nicht unbedingt,
dabei, es gibt natürlich sehr viele gute Gründe, warum man natürlich auch seine eigene Krankenakte auch einem Arzt sehr effizient vermitteln möchte. Und da ist natürlich so eine
Historie, in der all die Dinge dann auch wirklich äh klar gespeichert sind und wo man eben auch schnell sagen kann, okay hier, du hast da eine Unverträglichkeit für X, ja? Stell dir mal vor, du hast halt irgendeinen Notfall, Pipapo
Intensivstation,
feststellen, kann man dir jetzt ein bestimmtes Medikament geben oder nicht? Das sind ja dann auch so die Fälle. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass sie nur aus Spaß an der Freud jetzt mal da vor sich hin digitalisieren. Äh es gibt schon auch
äh Zwänger, die muss man in dieser Debatte berücksichtigen, mehr sage ich auch gar nicht.
Das mag ja alles sein, aber dieses irgendwie stell dir vor, du es ist ein Notfall und du hast eine Unverträglichkeit. Das ist wieder so, das ist,
Sorry, ist sehr, sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich. Und ähm also erstmal, dass man einen Unfall hat
zweitens, dass man dann noch jemand ist mit einer Unverträglichkeit. Und drittens, dass die Ärzte für diese eine Unverträglichkeit, die man haben kann, nicht sowieso einen Schnelltest da haben, ja? Ähm
deswegen finde ich das Argument echt nur sehr äh relativ eingeschränkt
gegenüber den großen gesellschaftlichen Risiken, die mit so einer zentralen Speicherung einhergehen. Ich bin da absolut deiner Meinung, wenn das irgendwie äh in meiner Hand bliebe, vor allem die die genaue Kontrolle darüber, wann wer Zugriff hat, also beispielsweise, dass ich irgendwie eine
Smartcard habe, mit der ich beim Arzt sein muss und dem quasi sagen kann, oder oder aus,
definieren kann, diesem Arzt gebe ich Zugriff auf Folgendes.
Für folgenden Zeitraum, wobei Zeitraum da natürlich via killefit ist, der Arzt macht sich ja als allererstes eine Kopie, aber so die Sammlung der Gesundheits äh Geschichte der Bevölkerung eines Landes in einer zentralen Datenbank. Ähm
ist natürlich äh wie immer werden auch wieder viele sagen, da kann man ganz viel tolle Forschungen machen, was man da alles rausfinden wird, welche Beschwerden korrelieren, die man von denen man vorher nicht wusste
Wunderbar, aber was am Ende dabei rauskommt, ist, dass Versicherungen das äh ausnutzen und es zum am Ende zum Nachteil für die Nutzer wird, die nämlich dann einfach keine Krankenversicherung mehr bekommen.
Fallen hier leider ins falsche Profil und so. Na ja, das ist richtig.
So und das äh da also Gesundheitswesen ich meine ein großes Problem ist irgendwie so dieses,
geht los mit Röntgenbildern, ne? Kriegst vom einen Arzt ein Röntgen-Dings gemacht und
muss dann wieder zu dem anderen Arzt gehen. Da werden irgendwie früher musstest du dann da mit den riesigen
Fotobelichteten Dingern hin und her fahren und dann hat der Arzt keins und dann denkt der Arzt sich, naja, wenn der Patient das nicht dabei ist, hat dann machen wir doch schnell nochmal hier, kann ich ja berechnen. Das heißt, da werden Menschen irgendwie stark verstrahlt, weil sie andauernd wieder gerönt werden, obwohl's unnötig ist. Das ist natürlich ein Punkt so,
Da kann man mit äh Digitalisierung drüber reden. Da sind wir aber noch weit von der Notwendigkeit entfernt, diese diese Daten, nämlich die zentral für ein ganzes Land zu speichern. Und diese Notwendigkeit will ich im Fall stellen. Alles andere super, mach das digital. Super
muss eh weg. Und auch diese CD Roms, also wenn ich da mit meinen Knie-CTs durch die Gegend gerannt bin, mit
komme ich mit einer Ziede rum, fand ich ja schon mal cool. Dann so äh immerhin, ja, aber ähm.
Dass die der zentrale Teil das zu zentralisieren und gesetzlich zu regeln äh,
halte ich für eine für eine großes Risiko und da sehe ich erstmal hauptsächlich nur Nutzen für,
Also wenig primär nutzen für die tatsächliche Gesundheit der Betroffenen. Also das da werde ich sehe ich wenig
Fälle, wo ich sagen würde, da wurde ein Schaden von der Person abgewandt,
anderenfalls von der Person nicht hätte abgewendet werden können. Effizientsteigerung für die ganzen Krankenkassen und Ärzte äh hin und her. Alles klar, sehe ich ein. Aber einen tatsächlichen Gesundheitsgewinn,
sich da für die betroffenen Personen nicht. Und ich denke grundsätzlich ist Gesundheitswesen eigentlich was, wo ein Staat einfach äh,
reinwerfen sollte,
Ähm und da vielleicht auch, also solange man irgendwie sagt, dass die Verfahren wissenschaftlich basiert sind und die Ärztin eine Rechenschaft darüber ablegen müssen, was sie machen, ja? Und sagt
bestimmte Dinge sind, indiziert bestimmte andere Dinge nicht. Äh
denke ich, dass es sinnvoll ist, ein Gesundheitssystem so zu halten, dass es von allen in Anspruch genommen werden kann und dass da vom vom Staat oder von wem auch immer äh so viel Geld draufgeworfen wird, dass alle gesund sind am Ende.
Ja
Amen.
Ja. Lassen wir das mal so stehen. Wie gesagt, ich bin noch nicht so tief in dem Thema drin. Noch nicht vielleicht, aber auf jeden Fall eine Debatte, die man sich in Österreich anschauen sollte.
Ja. Mehr habe ich nicht mehr.
War dann dein Beitrag,
sehr schön. Ja, dann äh.
Danken wir dir.
Noch ein bisschen äh hinlegen, ausruhen, gesund werden, ein paar Kongressvideos gucken. Ist ja auch sehr nett, ne.
Ja hallo, ich werde jetzt weiter an der Kampagne arbeiten. Das mache ich die nächsten zwei Monate durchgängig.
Ah, das ist das ist die Rückmeldung des wahren Aktivisten. Das wollten wir doch nur hören.
Thomas Fletterknopf wird in der Sendung äh zu sehen sein.
So ist es.
Juhu!
Alles klar. Ciao, Thomas. Gruß nach Wien. Bis bald, tschüss.
Tschüss. Ciao.
So
Kommen wir zurück zu NSA.
Ja
Einen Monat, einen Monat kein Logbuch und es gibt einen einen solchen riesigen Sack an,
NSA äh Neuigkeiten ähm wo man sich jetzt echt langsam überlegen muss, was äh was machen wir da überhaupt noch? Ähm,
Ich versuche mal so den letzten Monat irgendwie grob zusammenzufassen und werde da werde dem jetzt nicht gerecht und äh hoffe, das seht ihr nach. Ich habe eine äh eine leicht eine kleinere Linkssammlung dann zu dem Thema,
Es gab äh zunächst ging es, glaube ich, ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich auch Sachen vergessen. Es ging, glaube ich, los mit einer, äh mit ähm,
einer detaillierteren Erklärung, wie sie bei Mobiltelefon Bewegungsanalysen machen.
Mhm. Ja, das wie wie sie das durchführen, wie sie das konkret technisch äh.
Die technische Lösung. Es sah war relativ nah an dem, was ich äh grob schon mal so spekuliert hatte zu zu diesen
zu diesem Thema. Ähm äh dann ging es um das Nutzerfinger-Printing, ja, auch ein spannendes Thema. Auch hier nicht ähm,
ähm nichts wirklich Neues. Ich hatte das ja auch schon mal angesprochen, dass jeder, dass man als Internetnutzer relativ klaren äh Fingerprint hat. Ich hatte das mal erklärt, somit allein schon bei mir jetzt die E-Mail-Server, mit denen ich mich kontaktiere.
Wie ist eure heraussprudelt aus dem eigenen Rechner, genau.
Und ähm es gibt ja schon Jahre alte äh äh Demonstrationen,
wo die IFF eine Seite gebaut hat, die einfach mal alle Informationen, die ein Java Skript aus deinem Browser herauskratzen kann, nutzt. Und zwar ähm,
jene Informationen, die eigentlich nicht als Privatsphäre relevant gelten,
Beispielsweise die Auflösung des Fensters. Das sind alles Sachen, die Java, die man mit dem Java Skript herausfinden kann, die man ja auch dann braucht, damit der Java Skript vernünftig funktioniert, ne, dass man sagen kann, wie breit ist denn der Bildschirm? Davon mache ich jetzt so und so viel Prozent. Ähm,
Die haben dann die Schrifttypen, die installiert sind, geprüft, das Operating System, die Browserversion und so weiter,
und haben dann einen äh Fingerprint darüber errechnet und haben dann einem angezeigt, wie,
einzigartig dieser Browser Fingerprint für einen einzelnen für einen Nutzer ist. Das heißt, ähm
wenn jemand all das abfragt, was er alles so über dich äh also wie
eindeutig er dich erkennen kann. Und das waren alle Reihen diese Browserdaten waren schon irgendwie enorm zur zur Direktion eines Individuums. Wenn man dann jetzt noch wie die NSA irgendwie Trafficgewohnheiten dazu nimmt und was die Leute nicht alles äh sich anschauen können
ähm.
Dann äh hat man schon eine sehr gute Erkennung und wenn man dann, das war dann die Titelzeile, die die Journalisten sich rausgesucht haben. Wenn man dann noch die Cookies nimmt, zum Beispiel die Google Cookies, ja, dann hat man natürlich eine eindeutige Erkennung,
Denn Google vergibt ja jedem einzelnen Nutzern. Einen eindeutigen ähm Cookie.
Und Google benutzt halt fast jeder und deswegen ist das äh etwas, worauf man sich natürlich mühelos stürzen kann. Alles sehr naheliegend und die NSA ist an allem dran, was irgendwie naheliegend ist, das ist, glaube ich, auch so die Grunderkenntnis,
Jahres, ne? Also alles, was irgendwie gemacht werden kann,
wird gemacht und dann gibt's noch die Sachen, die fast unmöglich sind. Die werden auch gemacht. Und dann gibt's noch so ein paar Sachen, da ist noch keiner so richtig drauf gekommen.
Da arbeiten sie gerade dran.
Arbeiten sie dran und äh also es gibt da äh keinerlei Zurückhaltung ähm spätestens die,
mit dem letzten Kongresstag dann auch noch bekannt gewordenen Tao Sachen werden das zeigen, aber vielleicht bleiben wir mal in der Reihenfolge, zumindest der hier äh die wir hier äh haben.
Gab's noch die kleine Meldung des GCHQ,
überwachte das Telefonnetz der Ministerien in Berlin. Ja, das hat dann gar nicht mehr so viel Wind geschlagen, weil wir hatten ja schon unser Merkel-Fon, das heißt, der Neuigkeitswert äh war da jetzt offensichtlich noch zu gering.
Äh dann äh gibt es ein schönes äh
vier Unterwasserkabelsystem, das von Marseille über Nordafrika und die Golfstaaten nach Pakistan und Indien und dann weiter bis nach Singapur, Malaysia und Thailand führt. Da hängt die NSA auch dran
Warum auch nicht? Also es ist ja ein Unterwasserkabel, kann man sich ja mal anschauen. Ähm.
Währenddessen sitzt dann der Generalbundesanwalt da und sagt, äh NSA Speeranfähr Affäre gibt's nicht. Und ähm,
In den USA wurde dann äh debattiert, äh die Aussage eines Obama-Beraters, der sagt,
NSA-Vorratsdatenprogramm hat keine Anschläge verhindert. Ähm das allerdings mit der Einschränkung äh sagte, ja
dann muss es wohl ein anderes Programm gewesen sein, auf das sich die NSA in ihren oder die äh Geheimdienstbeauftragten der Regierung in ihren Aussagen
ähm,
Beziehen, ja, statt einfach mal zu sagen, das ist übrigens hier gelogen. Andererseits kann der Mann ja gar keine gesicherte Aussage treffen, weil die Anzahl der ähm,
die Anzahl der Programme ist ja inzwischen wirklich nicht mehr zu überschauen ja? Also das,
Wer weiß, was sie noch alles machen, vielleicht mit irgendwas davon, vielleicht ähm verhindern sie tatsächlich einen ähm,
ein ein Anschlag mal. Also die Hoffnung steht ja noch aus.
Na angeblich ist es ja, also unser Innenminister, äh ehemaliger, unser Landwirtschaftsminister hat ja gemeint, es könnten ja fünf sein oder so, vielleicht auch fünfzig. So genau weiß man das alles nicht. Ähm,
An der Stelle,
möchte ich einen Kongressvortrag äh empfehlen, nämlich ähm gehalten von einem Anwalt, der für die IF arbeitet, Kurt äh Opsal,
Genau, Kurt, Kurt, hast du den gesehen?
Hast du den gesehen? Nein, aber äh mich sehr äh sehr gefreut und das war äh der war natürlich in dem Track äh Politik äh Gesellschaft und ich habe äh schon sein äh Feedback gelesen, was äh überragend war.
Ja genau, also ähm Vortrag zweiundfünfzig fünfundfünfzig. Es gibt ja immer diese schöne Zahl, das äh solltet ihr euch äh merken, ja, das steht auch mal äh schön in den Dateinamen drin und so weiter, also wenn ihr euch nicht sicher seid, welcher Vortrag gemeint ist, der mit der ID zweiundfünfzig,
Fünfundfünfzig diese ist übrigens Younique über alle Kongresse hinweg. Ja, also es kommt nicht nächstes Jahr wieder vor
Äh, ja, also ein Scanner darklee, äh, erinnern. Und er hat einfach mal so alles zusammengefasst, was man so bisher so weiß, äh, wobei das eben nicht nur dieses Jahr, äh, zusammenfasst, sondern eben auch die Erkenntnisse der IF
zurück bis zweitausendfünf teilweise noch bis zweitausendeins, also auch so wie die Programme kamen.
Warum ich da jetzt grade drauf komme, abgesehen davon, dass eine Zusammenfassung an dieser Stelle immer äh sinnvoll ist.
Grade dieses Geeiere in der Öffentlichkeit mit,
Grade bei so Anhörungen des Parlaments, ja, wo dann äh Vertreter der NSA oder andere äh Vertreter der Regierung befragt werden, ob
denn in diesem oder jenen äh Programm das ein oder andere Böse getan worden sei, ja, wo das ja dann immer häufig immer abgewiegelt wird und jetzt so, nein, das haben wir nicht getan, ja?
Er führt auch sehr schön aus, wie es einerseits so ist, dass sie eben durch diese Vielzahl an Programmen und Coten haben, die sie haben, häufig so ist so, so, nein, wir haben die Geo-Location in diesem Programm nicht erfasst, ja, weil,
Dafür haben wir ein anderes Programm, ja, das hat einen anderen Namen und äh davon wisst ihr noch gar nichts. Das ist so der,
Der eine Trick, der gerne gemacht wird und was auch sehr schön rüberkam, ist, jetzt möchte ich mal wieder ein Wort, was du vorhin schon eingeführt hast, äh nochmal bemühen, ja, so eine perfide ähm,
Art und Weise mit Sprache umzugehen, ne? Sein Beispiel war dann eben so dieses äh die Frage war dann so, ob sie denn äh folgende Informationen,
sammeln würden so. Collect, ja und äh das wurde dann in dem Fall verneint.
Obwohl sie diese Daten sehr wohl abgeschnorchelt und auch gespeichert haben, aber ihre Argumentation ist, naja, äh
Ich würde ja jetzt, wenn ich ein Buch in einer Bibliothek habe, diese Information ja dann eigentlich erst eingesammelt haben, wenn ich dieses Buch auch selbst gelesen habe,
Aber sie speichern ja alles nur ab und würden ja nur, wenn's wirklich ein Anlass gäbe, da dann vielleicht auch wirklich mal drauf zugreifen. Also die Worte äh passen hier auch einfach schon gar nicht mehr.
Wichtiger Punkt, dass äh so argumentiert jetzt auch der BND gerade, äh die ja dann irgendwie neue Zahlen irgendwie für über ähm äh Datenabschnüffelung äh veröffentlicht haben und sagen, wir überwachen jetzt viel weniger. Ähm
und die Begründung, warum sie jetzt viel weniger überwachen, ist, dass ihre Filter besser geworden sind. Das heißt, sie hängen also die Automatisierten Filter,
Ähm.
Durchforsten immer noch dieselbe Daten.
Eine größere Datenmenge und brechen es auf weniger herunter, wo am Ende noch ein Mensch äh reinschauen muss. Ja, das ist äh also das ist,
sehr interessant, weil wenn man das jetzt mal zehn, fünfzehn Jahre weiterdenkt, dann wird demnächst alles nur noch algorithmisch ausgewertet. Wir werden von Computern kontrolliert, alle Dystopie ist äh,
ist, ist Skynet ist da und niemand überwacht dich mehr,
Keiner überwacht dich, weil ähm alles wird automatisch von den Computern gemacht. Das guckt ja jetzt keiner mehr rein, ja? Du bist doch nicht überwacht. Ja, du wirst zwar sofort von der Drohne erschossen, wenn du irgendwie dein Fahrrad falsch parkst, aber du bist doch nicht überwacht,
So, das das ist das, wo es hingeht. Und da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein. Also man muss man muss ganz besonders aufpassen, Definition von Überwachung muss bleiben. Kontakt,
mit meiner Information findet statt, ob jetzt durch einen technischen Filter oder äh oder auch nicht
ja? Aber zu sagen, erst das, wo äh, wo jemand, wo unser äh Geheimdienst äh Personal äh reingeklickt hat und weil sie sich nicht einen Check Markt gemacht hat, das haben wir jetzt überwacht. Alles andere nicht
Ähm und vor allem bei den ganzen Analysen, die gefahren werden. Ich sage das, aber da habe ich schon hundert Mal gesagt. Wenn ich.
Wenn ich eine Analyse mache, die, ich hatte grade dieses Beispiel mit dem äh Fahrrad falsch geparkt. Ja, das war dann das wird ja in dem EU-geförderten Programm Indekt, werden ja genau solche Sachen gemacht. Massen von Menschen filmen äh und abnormes Verhalten erkennen.
Ja, das heißt zu sagen, okay, dieser Mensch läuft,
auffällig langsam, wir ohne eine Gehbehinderung zu haben, der ist jetzt auffällig, den schauen wir uns jetzt an, ja? Ähm um,
anormales Verhalten auf erkennen zu können, brauche ich eine sehr große Datenbasis dafür, was normales Verhalten ist. Das heißt, ich muss alles überwachen,
Um dann zu erkennen, wo ist jetzt überhaupt Abweichung,
Was ist etwas besonderes? Und die Datenbasis, je größer die ist, umso besser. Das heißt, ich muss alles überwachen, um die wenigen,
Abweichung davon zu erkennen. Und dann zu sagen, naja, nur wenn es eine Abweichung ist, dann ist es ja auch wirklich Überwachung.
Wir überwachen überhaupt nicht. Wir betreiben lediglich Normalitätserfassung.
Ja? Und äh der Stelle wollte ich auch noch gleich nochmal ein anderes äh Zitat reinschmeißen. Die äh US-Botschaft, wann sich ja jetzt gerade an die CSU an, weil die offensichtlich irgendwie erstmal
Argumenten am äh noch am zugänglichsten äh zu sein scheint. Ja, der hat's dann mit Seehofer äh getroffen.
Und dann gab's dieses geile äh Zitat, ich muss das mal zitieren aus diesem heißen Artikel, das ist wirklich unglaublich, ja? Details zu den Abhöreinrichtungen auf dem Dach der US-Botschaft in Berlin, gab Amazon nicht Preis. Der bestätigte aber, ja
Wir haben Kommunikationsgeräte auf dem Dach unserer Botschaft. Jeder andere Botschaft auf der Welt habe das aber auch. Und dann,
Wir sind eine Kommunikationsorganisation, Botschaft bedeutet Botschaft.
Geile Sau. Ja, dafür kann man dem schon echt mal fünf Mark flettern.
Was ein Spruch, Botschaft, ja, ja.
Überhaupt? Wir werden überhaupt nicht überwacht, ja? Sondern äh die kommunizieren einfach nur die ganze Zeit und äh wir können sie ja nicht einfach die ganze Zeit dran hindern, ne.
Botschaft bedeutet.
Schön, schön, schön.
Ja. Ja äh ich weiß nicht, deine Zusammenfassung der Ereignisse äh.
Es kommt ja noch, bin noch nicht fertig.
Ja ja, meine ich doch.
Es kam dann nämlich der ähm,
der äh groß erwartete und groß angekündigte und groß hundertachtzig Mal verlegte äh Talk von ähm,
Jacob Applebaum, den er ja auch schon äh groß angekündigt hatte, Monate im Voraus. Äh partout,
Es gab zwei Talks, gab,
Aussplitterung der Gruppen, die äh zuerst zusammen einen Talk machen wollten, weil Hintergründe brauche ich mich da nicht zu äußern. Ähm und da stellte er dann das äh Taylor Excess Operations Programm nochmal genauer vor. Und da ging's so um den,
ähm Katalog, insbesondere der äh oder spezifischer der Hardware, die die NSA so hat,
oder die ihr zur Verfügung steht, um Telefone zu in
infizieren, ja? Oder um Computer zu infizieren. Da geht's dann um kleine Geräte, die irgendwie eingebaut werden, manipulierte Monitorkabel, ähm kleine Sachen, die man in deinen in deinen Computer einlöten kann und ähm also eine ganze Menge an,
ein, ja, so Spionage Hardware und Programmen.
Und Logistik.
Und Logistik, klar, dass sie irgendwie Amazon-Pakete abfangen und ein neues, dein neuer Computer schon.
Ja, stell dir mal vor, du hast so einen Dell-Laptop irgendwie bei Amazon,
Dann bist du ja schon mal mit deinem Namen da mehr oder weniger gut äh ortbar, dass die NSA diese Informationen hat, ist auch klar. Was der Talk klargestellt hat, ist sie sind nicht nur,
irgendwie im Nachgang dann da dran. Dann sind mehr oder weniger auch in Echtzeit an den Sachen dran. Da gibt's ja noch mehr Details
wahrscheinlich gleich noch dazu. Ähm so sehnt sich dazu in der Lage und haben das wohl auch schon getan, in welchem
Maß hat es getan wird, weiß ich nicht, habe ich jetzt nicht so raus hören und lesen äh können, vielleicht habe ich nicht genug gelesen, aber äh
es kann sehr wohl sein, dass dieses Gerät in dem Moment, wo es halt dann zugestellt wird, bereits schon einmal durch äh die NSA Spezialisten Hände durchgegangen ist und dann teilweise im,
Plastik,
äh Hardware untergebracht wird, also selbst wenn es auseinanderbaut, das Mainboard anschaut, siehst du nichts, ja? Aber du hast quasi die Wanze einfach
direkt im Guss und äh andere Varianten, Internetports, wo noch äh so ein so ein Funk
Teil drin steckt, also hinten, da, wo man den Stecker äh reinsteckt, dasselbe auch in Kabeln. Also eine unglaubliche Bandbreite an, wo man alles noch rangehen kann und äh Strategien, wie man eben auch Wireless dann diese Geräte äh,
hören kann.
Ähm ja
Also ist, ist absolut Schocking. Ich will da mal ein Argument äh vortragen, was äh ein äh äh guter Bekannter äh Vertrauter von mir so anbringt, zitiere das jetzt nicht namentlich, aber mal so nur als Argument mal in den Raum gestellt. Der ähm,
sagt, okay, ähm so ein bisschen, bisschen Überwachung muss der Staat machen.
Prämisse, die ja jetzt mal so voraussetzt, die und man kann sich jetzt quasi überlegen,
soll der Staat eine Massenüberwachung machen, um alle zu erfassen? Haben wir genug jetzt gerade bei der NSA, ja, offensichtlich überwachen sie jede Kommunikation, die wir irgendwie tätigen oder,
möchte man ihnen die Möglichkeit schaffen.
Gezielt vorzugehen.
Gezielt, also mit anderen Worten der Staat kann alle überwachen.
Aber soll er auch alle gleichzeitig überwachen können,
Und da wäre jetzt die Frage, eigentlich diese gesamten Gerätschaften, die in Jops Talk dann jetzt als neue äh Enthüllungen äh da ähm dargestellt wurden oder oder vorgestellt wurden, Entschuldigung, dargestellt ist der falsche vorgestellt wurden, sind alles,
Ähm gezielte und hochaufwendige ähm.
Gar nicht alles. Also wo man das auf die äh versteht ein Argument und das ist sicherlich auch,
ja oder wessen Argument das auch immer ist, das kann ich nachvollziehen, das ist auch sicherlich äh ein Stück weit richtig, allerdings viele dieser Maßnahmen sind teilweise auch nur erst dann wirklich möglich, ähm,
in dem vorher Largescale, Unsicherheiten überhaupt erst eingebracht wurden, Stichwort
Zahlengeneratoren in äh Prozessoren, um Krypto von vorne rein äh zu schwächen
oder eben auch so Fehler in Systemen, die nicht gemeldet werden und dann quasi drin gelassen werden, weil die NSA könnte sie ja dann für, ob das zielgerichtet oder nicht zielgerichtete Maßnahme ist, ist an der Stelle dann auch egal.
Später dann nutzen, ja? Oder eben dann auch,
eine und dann ist es wieder massenhaft, ja, so dieses bewusste Ausnützen von äh von Sicherheitslücken, von denen man eben einfach weiß,
ein Teil des Talks bezog sie auch noch, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie dieses Programm hieß, das hatte auch so einen finsteren Namen,
Dass sie halt äh auch in der Lage sind, quasi Zugriffe auf Beispiel war, glaube ich, Yahoo.
Com irgendwie in Echtzeit abzufangen und dann eben mit ihren eigenen Servern schneller zu antworten und dann eben in diese Webseiten, Chartcode zu injizieren, um dann eben Rechner zu infizieren. Also es ist da ist schon sehr viel,
Taylor ist das, ja, es ist schon zugeschnitten, aber dass der Anzug passt dann eben auch noch zu vielen Leuten.
Ja, also so werden ja äh hatten wir ja auch schon so wir, so werden ja äh Staatstrojaner äh auf die Zielsysteme gebracht. Ja, das äh
kommen sie als Softwareupdate, was irgendwie dann beim Provider äh abgefangen und durch eine infizierte ähm Ersetze.
Ich hatte aber auch den Eindruck, dass man sich ja, aber ich hatte aber auch den Eindruck, dass sie im Prinzip hier die NSA sich schafft.
Ja klar.
Die sie dann halt im Zweifelsfall zum Einsatz bringt. Und das kann nicht okay sein.
Das kann alles nicht okay sein, was sie da macht.
Ja gut, ich meine dieses James Bond Arsenal, ja das
ist ja so ein bisschen so der, der, der, der, der Füllfederhalter mit äh mit Munition, ja, so in, in, in digital so diese ganzen Spezialkabel et cetera. Das ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Also, ich glaube, die
wenn die schon am nächsten James Bond arbeiten, guten vorstellen, dass sie ihr Drehbuch schon zweimal wieder weggeschmissen haben, nach diesem Jahr, ja, weil das einfach,
nur noch. Genau. Also die müssen sich richtig was einfallen lassen, wenn sie irgendwie noch so ein bisschen in der Zukunft operieren wollen.
Also da in ein interessanter äh Vortrag. Ähm aber da muss ich jetzt tatsächlich sagen so, das hat mich jetzt nicht mehr überrascht. Also beispielsweise ein manipulierter äh IFA Net äh Stecker, ja? Ähm.
Was mich überrascht hat, war diese Darreichung, also dass es da wirklich so einen internen Katalog mit Preisen gab und so, also ein schöner Begriff, der in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang viel ist ja, diese,
industrialisierte Form von äh Geheimdiensttätigkeit, ja.
Schöner na soll ich da jetzt mal? Ja doch da mache ich einen kleinen Plug.
Am ersten Tag des Kongresses. Dieser Vortrag war am vierten,
Am ersten Tag haben Karsten und Luca einen Angriff äh zur Trojanisierung einer SIM-Karte vorgestellt. Carsten und Luca, mein äh,
mit denen ich zusammenarbeite. Ähm haben einen Angriff auf eine SIM-Karte vorgestellt,
der ähm sich dann nachher tatsächlich auch so in diesen NSA-Folien wiederfand. Das heißt ja, mal nebenbei bewiesen,
oder gezeigt, dass wir oder dass bei uns eben dieser solche Forschung gefunden wird, gemacht wird
veröffentlicht wird und an der, an der Behebung mitgewirkt wird. Und vier Tage später äh trat dann äh auf die Bühne und sagt, ja übrigens, so, das ist nicht nur ein theoretisches Angriffsszenario, was da jetzt irgendwie so
von einem äh äh irgendwie Hackerunternehmen gefunden wurde und vorgestellt wurde, sondern das machen die schon seit Jahren, ja? Dieser Katalog war ja irgendwie äh den er da zitiert hat, der ist ja wiederum auch vier Jahre alt, ja, äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche, das
war alles irgendwie zweitausendneun oder so. Und äh vier Jahre später kommt dann ähm quasi ein unabhängiges Forschungslab
so weit, dass sie da ein, eins, ein kleines Ding aus den riesigen Katalog äh mit
guten ein, zwei Jahren Forschung, dann mal so vorstellen und sagen, guck mal, was theoretisch möglich wäre, da muss man mal eine Sicherheitslücke schließen und ähm ja, das war schon,
äh
Ja, das ist der Vortrag fünf vier vier neun, mobile Network Attack Evolution Carsten Melite. Ja, auch alles runterladbar wird verlinkt.
Ja, du sagst das so schnell, da muss ich gleich mal noch einfügen, den Link hatte ich jetzt noch nicht. Ähm ja.
Tja, das waren jetzt mal nur so die letzten vier Wochen und wir haben wahrscheinlich die Hälfte vergessen.
Ja, sicherlich.
War auch nicht möglich, mehr dem Ganzen überhaupt noch ausreichend Aufmerksamkeit entgegenzubringen. War ja auch Weihnachten ein bisschen, ne?
Ich denke, danach kann man dann echt einfach sagen, äh also.
Jetzt ist auch egal, was?
Jetzt ist äh es gab ja zwei zwei schöne zwei schöne Sachen dann noch. In dem Security Night Mass Talk, der äh von Ron und Frank, der ja jedes Jahr äh so Kongress äh Programm ist, letzte Veranstaltung ist immer Security.
Nightmares, wo sie dann hochhielten, die Situation der IT Security ist folgende und dann war eine weiße Fahne zu sehen. Und das,
das ist schon das, das, das, das Fazit, aber da hatten sie ja sogar äh Bügeleisen, die mit äh mit WLAN kommen, ja, also mit,
Und wenn du dir das überlegst, dann brauchst dich ja, wenn wenn dir schon die Chinesen ein Bügeleisen schicken, was irgendwie dein WLAN abhört, ähm dann äh ist es,
in der Relation nicht mehr besonders überraschend, dass dir die Amerikaner ein Iphanet Adapter schicken, der auch noch WLAN hat, ja? Zumal das grundsätzlich viele von diesen von diesen Sachen nicht alle, aber einige, ähm.
Von einem von einem Studenten irgendwie als Proof of Concept in in zwei, drei Wochen äh zusammengelötet sind. Nicht alle
Also spätestens wenn man davon ein Kilowatt Röntgenstrahlung äh redet, um Monitor abzuhören, dann spricht man natürlich von einer etwas anderen äh Dimension
aber so kleine Hardware äh Trojaner äh zu bauen, die man die Tastatureingaben abfangen und solche solche Späßchen. Das sind ja ähm,
Das hat man, stellt immer mal jemand vor und zeigt mal jemand oder vor allen Dingen bei irgendeiner Security-Konferenz wurden dann auch äh iPhone Ladegeräte gezeigt, die mit einem kleinen Mikroprozessor dann versuchen, dass das iPhone irgendwie zu infiltriert,
und was nicht alles ähm was man immer,
Bei sowas dachte ich so, ja okay, aber dafür brauche ich ja Hardware-Zugriff. Und wenn ich Hardware-Zugriff habe, dann kann ich am Ende sowieso die Büchse auseinandernehmen. Da steht mir nicht mehr viel im Wege. Ähm,
je nachdem wie viel Aufwand ich äh dann noch bereit bin, zu betreiben. Und da da denke ich ist auch das Entscheidende ist hier, dass dass sie nicht nur diese
diese Hardware haben, was sich nicht besonders überraschend finde, sondern wie du schon sagtest, die Infrastruktur, um dir die auch unterzujubeln.
Vor allem in Zeiten von Amazon Prime, ja, wenn du sagst, okay, schnell Bestellung hier, ich will meinen Computer irgendwie morgen früh um zwölf haben, ja. Na ja.
Gut, Detox, alle auf MediaticCDE, die Links in unseren Shownotizen.
So sieht's aus.
Ich habe gerade festgestellt, man kann diese Nummern tatsächlich einfach da so in dieses Suchfeld eingeben und schwups ist man da.
Diese Nummern sind äh sind super, die ähm die gelten schon so wirklich, also auch in internen Gesprächen dann so als Younique, Identify für einen Talk. Ähm vier Zahlen sagen und dann ist gut.
Habe ich mal eingefügt.
Hast du eingeführt? Hast du gut eingeführt?
Ah, heute schein die Zukunft.
Äh gut eingeführt.
Wir kommen zum nächsten Thema, wir sind wieder in Deutschland. Wir haben ja noch ganz die ganze Deutschland äh die ganze Deutschlanddrama auch noch vor uns.
Mhm.
Die Streaming-Abmahnungen. Äh wir erinnern uns, die.
Ah, die Porno, die Schaukelvideos, Entschuldigung.
Abmahnung, die an die Leute gingen, die Streams geschaut haben und da hatte ich ja schon oder hatten wir ja schon angedeutet, dass das.
Licht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen. Kann.
Nicht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen,
es verdichteten sich dann auch die Hinweise, dass äh sie dass dort ein readdirector irgendwie genutzt wurde. Also sie haben irgendwie bestimmte Domains, die Tippfehler quasi sind und haben dann sogar noch ihren eigenen
irgendwie eine eine Filterinfrastruktur mitgenutzt und es auf jeden Fall äh scheinbar nicht das System von Retube selber infiltriert, sondern,
sich auf die Quote der Vertipper und so äh allein beschränkt. So scheint, scheint im Moment die Indizienlage zu sein. Jetzt hat der,
Anbieter Redtube erstmal ähm eine einstweilige Verfügung erwirbt gegen äh,
diese äh VR-Cive AG und ihr untersagt Abmahnschreiben an die Nutzer der Internet äh Plattform zu senden, in denen eine Urheberrechtsverletzung behauptet wird. Das heißt, die dürfen jetzt gar nicht mehr abmahnen per einstweiliger Verfügung.
Mhm.
Ähm,
und dann haben die, hat die Linksfraktion in äh Person von Ziniak und äh Gregor Kiezy mal die Bundesregierung gefragt, ja äh hier, ne, interessanter Vorfall. Wir haben da mal ein paar Fragen,
unter anderem hält denn die Bundesregierung Streaming,
Also den Konsum eines Streamangebotes für den Verstoß gegen das Urheberrecht. Und da kam dann eine äh vorsichtige, aber immerhin eine eindeutige,
Antwort aus dem äh Justizministerium, wo gesagt wurde, naja, nach dem aktuellen äh Stand des Rechtes ähm,
halten wir den Konsum von Streams erstmal für unbedenklich,
Mit dem vorsichtigen Verweis darauf, dass äh da noch das äh sage ich mal höchstrichterlich der höchstrichterliche Entscheidung ausstehen
ob denn dieses kurzzeitige Kopieren in den Arbeitsspeicher beziehungsweise Zwischenspeicher auf dem Rechner äh eine tatsächliche
Kopie im Sinne des Urheberrechtes darstellt,
wo man ja jetzt durchaus argumentieren kann, dass nein, denn diese Kopie ist ja nicht eine dauerhafte, also über die Kopie da zu argumentieren, denke ich, äh wäre dann mal überraschend technisch argumentiert äh für für.
Für die Bundesregierung.
Die Bundesregierung und äh.
Geschehen noch Zeichen und Wunder, ich sag's ja. Technische Schackung jetzt auch auf Bundesregierungsebene, wo soll das nur hinführen? Am Ende braucht man den CCC nicht mehr.
Ja, ich äh bin mal ähm bin mal gespannt.
Weit von entfernt.
Aber äh im Moment als erstmal so, dass die ähm,
sagt dir zu unser, unser Justizminister, der mehrfach schon überrascht hat in seinen ersten Tagen seines Amtes,
dass er das für unbedenklich hält und entsprechend äh steht natürlich auch diese gesamte Abmahn äh Nummer von von dieser äh Rechtsanwaltskanzlei da jetzt auf äh sehr, sehr äh,
sehr dünnem Eis und äh wie gesagt, das Geld sollte man denen nicht geben.
Ja, ja, ja. Da haben sie sich aber auch wirklich äh
Haben sie sich auch wirklich angelegt, ja? Also ich weiß nicht genau, wer das diese diese Indizienkette da die Beweise berichtet wurde, zusammengetragen hat, da hieß es, glaube ich, ein Leser, ein irgendjemand, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, namentlich ist der
benannt worden, der da geforscht hat, findiger Leser, heißt es hier. Ähm ja,
sehr findig, ja? Also das ist so diese Art von äh Recherche, wo man sich, glaube ich, so als Anwalt in Deutschland im Abmahnbusiness nur vorchten kann und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da auch sehr viel mehr Fälle da draußen gibt, die durchaus mal den einen oder anderen findigen Leser verdient hätten.
Findige Leser sind.
Oder auch Hörer natürlich.
Ja, also diese ganze Abmahnsache, das ist ähm.
Fortgesetztes Trauerspiel.
Es ist wirklich ein fortgesetztes Trauerspiel und ähm die die
die ihre Anzahl an Kanzleien, die das machen, ist ja auch wirklich äh sehr gering, ne, das ist äh gibt da glaube ich nur zwei, drei, deren Namen dann immer wieder fallen und die einfach diesen Prozess, ja, in jeder Form,
wirklich Industrialisiert haben, ne? Die hängen in den Towers drin, da fällt automatisch das raus. Das ist bis zum, also vermutlich,
äh bis zum Schreiben des Serienbriefes einfach ein komplett automatischer Prozess, der da stattfindet. Ähm,
Entsprechend ja auch die Erfahrung, dass man die sehr gut aus dem Trip bringt, indem man da einfach mal äh.
Erstmal selber einen Brief hinschreibt.
Frage stellt und pipapo, weil dann funktioniert dieser Maschine, dieser Maschine, der den Vorgang nicht mehr, also dieses Modell funktioniert eigentlich nur, wenn sich alle ducken. Und wenn dann irgendwie alle, also wenn angenommen ist, ist natürlich unrealistisch, wie machen sie's ja auch, aber angenommen es wäre so,
alle, die da jetzt angeschrieben wurden.
Individuelle Antworten mit mit Fragen schicken.
Ja mit Fragen, Auskunft, trallala nach Paragraph XY und so weiter, ja? Äh der Laden würde ihn auseinanderfliegen, weil die mit fast nichts anderem mehr beschäftigt werden. Und dann lohnt sich natürlich der ganze Spaß auch nicht mehr.
Ähm
grundsätzlich nochmal kurz dazu, weil ich jetzt in einer anderen Situation auch äh grade wieder dieses Thema hatte, wenn ihr eine Abmahnung bekommt oder wenn ihr euch überhaupt in der Situation, in eurem Leben befindet, dass
ein Anwalt euch etwas schickt und sagt, unterschreibt das und schickt es an mich zurück. Und dieser Anwalt ist nicht euer eigener, sondern der Gegenseite. Tut das,
unter keinen Umständen. So. Es kann sein, dass ihr juristisch äh verpflichtet seid, äh etwas
grob in der Richtung zu schreiben, aber in der Regel wird der gegnerische Anwalt euch natürlich etwas unterschieben, womit ihr mehr
Rechte abtretet als ihr eigentlich juristisch dazu verpflichtet seid. Also unter ne klar bei diesen Unterlassungserklärungen die müssen dann mit Hilfe eines äh,
Anwaltes eurer Wahl modifiziert werden,
um eben da, dass da kein Schuldeingeständnis drin ist und wart nicht alles. Also da ganz vorsichtig sein, was euch der gegnerische Anwalt schickt, äh das solltet ihr unter keinen Umständen unterschreiben, sondern eben selber formulieren und äh
entsprechend dann.
Genau, schon gar nicht, wenn das mit irgendwelchen äh astronomischen Gebühren verbunden ist, die sich auch meistens nur aus der Nase gezogen haben. Na ja.
So viel so viel zu den Streaming-Abmahnungen. Hoffentlich äh fliegt denen das noch mal richtig um die Ohren.
Ja, das könnte noch ein Spaß werden,
Es gab's ein paar neue Besetzungen. Äh wir haben da wieder eine neue Hoffnung. Neue Hoffnung am Horizont, ja. Frische Kräfte werden äh ins Feld geführt. Wir haben eine neue.
Bleibt jetzt nur noch auf die Hoffnung.
Man muss das ja auch mal positiv sehen, ja. Ich meine, die Bundesregierung hat sich immerhin dazu durchgerungen, einen neuen Datenschutzbeauftragte zu ernennen. Da äh kann man sich doch gar nicht vorstellen, äh dass sie nicht ähm alles nur erdenkliche dafür getan haben,
Die größtmögliche Expertin an Land zu ziehen.
Also ich glaube, die gute Nachricht hier ist, ähm das Amt wurde nicht abgeschafft.
Die Schlechte ist, es wurde mit äh Frau Vosshoff besetzt. Ähm,
die hat ähm ihr den Einzug in den Bundestag nicht mehr geschafft. Sie ist im Wahlkreis von äh Steinmeier angetreten und hat dort dann äh nicht den Einzug geschafft.
So nicht über die Liste äh ausreichend abgesichert.
Offensichtlich Liste irgendwie so weit hinten, dass sie selbst darüber nicht reingekommen ist, selbst bei dem astronomischen Ergebnis, äh, dass die CDU eingefahren hat.
Was die CDU eingefahren hat? Also mit anderen Worten, sie hat eigentlich innerhalb der CDU kein nennenswertes.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich äh so sagen. Diese Frau hat keinen nennenswerten Standing gehabt
und äh stand jetzt vor der äh Altersarmut und da hat sich dann die CDU erbarmt ähm und mit der Tradition gebrochen, dass man das Amtes äh Bundesdatenschützers oder des Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit
mit Juristen oder hochdekorierten Beamten aus dem Innenministerium besetzt
gebrochen und äh dafür dann äh dieses Amt dieser Frau zur Verfügung gestellt.
Über die man ja sicherlich schon viel gehört hat im Bereich Datenschutz.
Ja, äh man hat äh im Bereich Datenschutz äh von ihr vor allem gehört, dass sie für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt hat zu ihrer Zeit im Parlament für die Onlinedurchsuchung, also den Staatstrojaner.
Oh, aber sie kann doch nicht für alles sein.
Nein, sie ist auch gegen was, sie ist gegen Whistleblauer Schutz.
Ah, okay. Ah.
Volksentscheide pro Parteitimm pro Parteispenden von Unternehmen.
Mhm.
Aber jetzt kommt's, Datenschutz, man würde meinen Datenschutz, sie ist gegen den Kauf von Steuerdaten,
allerdings nicht aus Datenschutzgründen, sondern weil der Staat kein Hehler ist. Ähm und sie ist,
sie ist äh sie würde gerne die Zuwanderung in äh auf unseren heiligen Boden äh nach den ökonomischen Interessen äh des Landes sortieren.
Also ein profiliertes äh Portfolio, mit dem sie hier eintritt.
Denke auch aus Sicht der CDU ist das ein sehr profiliertes Portfolio, um ihr genau äh diesen Posten zu geben.
Ja
Jetzt muss man natürlich.
Das nennt man dann wohl Parteisoldatin.
Genau, Parteisoldaten müssten dann irgendwann auch nochmal was was äh ordentliches bekommen,
Also die wenn man jetzt so rückblickend auf diese Personalie, ist das natürlich eine eine äh,
Die größte Katastrophe, die man sich vorstellen kann für dieses Amt, andererseits,
man ja nicht ausschließen, dass die Frau äh die Aufgabe des äh Bundesdatenschützers
ebenso ernst nimmt wie ihre vorangegangene Aufgabe äh des Parteisoldaten. Das heißt, äh beziehungsweise der Parteisoldat hin. Das heißt, ähm.
Man will ja jetzt die Frau nicht vorverurteilen. Es wäre jetzt wenig überraschend, wenn sie bei ihren,
Bisherigen Entscheidungen und Einstellungen äh bleiben würde. Es wäre aber natürlich eine umso tollere äh Überraschung,
wenn sie jetzt irgendwie in dieser äh plötzlichen Machtposition, mit der man sie da äh ausgestattet hat, ähm Entscheidungen äh treffen würde, die,
der Aufgabe des Amtes äh entsprechen.
Weiß aber jetzt schon, dass wenn Pitta sich diese Sendung anhört, dass er in diesem Moment etwas schmunzeln muss.
Peter Scharr äh hat sich äh ganz spezifisch ähm ich habe ja seinen Vortrag beim äh dreißig C drei äh gesehen. Habe ich auch ein schönes Foto von ihm gemacht. Ähm
hat äh darum um Verständnis gebeten, dass er sich zu seiner Nachfolgerin nicht äußern möchte,
Das war äh das war natürlich mehr als tausend Worte und war sehr, sehr schön,
Ähm aber ähm sagen wir mal so, also die Frau kann es jetzt der der Welt zeigen,
Ich will nur nicht, also was soll ich jetzt ich meine, die Benennung dieser Person spricht für sich. Der Hintergedanke, den den offensichtlich, der dahinter stand, spricht auch für sich. Das einhundertein ähm wahlberechtigte Bundestagsabgeordnete aus der Koalition,
ihr nicht die Stimme gegeben haben, spricht auch für sich. Also es war ähm,
Sie wurde ja quasi äh von der CDU vorgeschlagen oder von der CDU CSU vorgeschlagen. Die SPD hat dann gesagt, na gut, da dulden wir, finden wir nicht toll, aber da da brechen wir jetzt auch keinen Streit vom Zaun,
Und ähm bei dem bei dem bei der Abstimmung ähm fehlt mir dann einhundertein Stimmen.
Also hätte sie also fehlten aus der Koalition, aber sie hat natürlich genug Stimmen bekommen, weil sie hat ja den.
Sie wurde gewählt, aber er aber die große Koalition ist eine große Koalition, da können auch mal hundert nicht mitstimmen.
Na ja, ich meine gut, Frau Merkel hat ja auch nicht alle äh Stimmen bekommen zur Kanzlerin Wahl, also.
Aber so sieht.
Es immer. Ja.
So sieht's aus, ja. Also, Datenschützer, äh Datenschutz ähm wird jetzt spannend. Wird jetzt wirklich spannend. Ähm,
Den Vortrag von Peter Schaiss, den ich da auch äh äh zu empfehlen, haben wir auch äh nochmal verlinkt.
Genau fünf, sechs, zwo, drei.
Acht Jahre lang war der äh äh deutscher bundesdeutscher Datenschützer,
und ähm hat da so ein bisschen einfach mal über diese Aufgabe referiert und über äh die Herausforderung,
und über das, was er äh eben äh als Geboten sieht. Äh wir erinnern uns, er hat ja dann für seine Arbeit als Datenschützer eine sehr ähm,
ein ein schlechtes Arbeitszeugnis äh bekommen vom Friedrich,
äh der der meine ich sagte, dass er ja als Datenschützer dann doch schon sehr einseitig gewesen wäre?
Ich meine, Entschuldigung, der Mann ist Datenschützer, ja, was soll der machen? Der die Aufgabe ist datenschutz. Ähm also schon sehr ähm sehr interessant,
ist da sicherlich mit einiger äh mit einiger Frustration gegangen und mit einiger Ernüchterung. Vortrag auf jeden Fall ganz interessant und wir werden jetzt mal schauen,
Ob dann die gute Frau äh Forshof in der Lage sein wird, äh uns da nochmal zu überraschen. Andrea Astrid Voßhof.
Ja. Go.
Andrea Astrid, Astrid und Andrea. Andreas. Andrea Astrid. Okay, alles klar.
Kommen wir mal zu der,
Wir haben ja jetzt schon von der, von unserem neuen Justizminister gesprochen. Wir haben auch schon äh von unserer neuen Bundesdatenschützerin gesprochen. Wir haben aber noch gar nicht darauf gesprochen, dass ja ähm die große Koalition jetzt ihre Minister hat.
Ja, na doch, wir haben eins schon erwähnt. Genau, ja. Ja.
Genau, ja, aber es gibt ja noch mehr. Ähm warte mal, vielleicht bevor ich jetzt hier meine Liste anschaue, gucke ich mal ganz.
Zwei habe ich schon erwähnt, den Landwirtschaftsminister, haben wir schon erwähnt und den Justizminister.
Jetzt muss ich mal ganz schnell schauen, äh.
Weiß nicht, wer der Landwirtschaftsminister ist? Doch, das weißt du. Habe ich dich auf dem linken Bein erwischt?
Ich weiß das mit äh ja Hans-Peter Friedrich. Ja.
Landwirtschaftsminister, der sich immer wieder klug zu bestimmten Dingen äußert. Was äh ich weiß nicht gar nicht, ob wir's neben äh bei erwähnt haben, also,
neue Datenschützerin, also die Position des Bundesdeutschen Datenschutz Obersten, ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt das Ding offiziell, Bundesbeauftragter finden.
Für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit.
Bundesbeauftragte untersteht, faktisch dem Innenministerium,
Daran hat sich nichts geändert und das ist auch bedauerlich, aber es war halt auch nicht damit zu rechnen, aber äh in der Zukunft denke ich mal, wäre es schon sinnvoll, politisch darauf hinzuarbeiten, dass äh hier diese Unabhängigkeit, die da äh eigentlich erwartet äh wird
dass die auch mal de facto hergestellt wird.
So ist es.
So und jetzt.
Ja, vielleicht also ich hoffe, ich habe sie alle. Ähm Frau von der Leyen.
Ja, unsere Spezialfreundinnen im Bereich Netzpolitik.
Spezialfreundin der Netzpolitik ist jetzt Verteidigungsministerin.
Verteidigt unsere Freiheit, die es am Hindu-Kusch.
So und ich da sage ich gar, sage ich wenig zu. Ähm,
aber ich denke, dass sie aus sehr gut qualifiziert ist, denn wir erinnern uns alle an ihr äh Interview im Hamburger Abendblatt, wo sie,
uns alle davor warnte, dass Kinderseelen zerfetzt werden. Das heißt, eine eine
Sprache, eine eine bildhafte Sprache, die wir als Nation dann auch brauchen von unserer Verteidigungsministerin, um in den nächsten Krieg zu ziehen und irgendwo ein Land in Schutt und Asche zu legen, weil da
Kinderseelen zerfetzt werden oder die Brutstätte und Hort des Terrorismus sind,
Dafür wird sie äh eine gute Besetzung sein. Finde dazu kann ich äh Angela Merkel nur grad gratulieren.
Ja
Wenn uns jemand in den nächsten Krieg führen kann, dann auf jeden Fall,
Ursula von der Leyen, das wird toll, da können wir auf auf wunderschöne Sprache setzen. Ähm da werden wir noch einige rhetorische äh Herausforderungen für den Maha haben, um sie dann beim einunddreißig zweiunddreißig dreiunddreißig, vierunddreißig,
zu tragen.
Ja, naja, vielleicht können sie sich ja mal äh um diese zerfetzten Soldatenseelen äh erstmal kümmern. Äh haben, glaube ich, sicherlich den entsprechenden Schaden da an vielen Stellen schon äh genommen und von daher ist er vielleicht dann auch erstmal an der richtigen Stelle.
Na ja, aber jetzt haben wir ja ein ganz tolles äh Ding, also die CDU muss man auch sagen, also äh sie folgt, sie ist sagen wir mal sehr ähm,
Konservativ, ja, also verankert in der Vergangenheit. Hm und hält auch äh,
immer hoch, ja? Also Helmut Kohl und sein beliebter aus äh,
Ausdruck zu den Datenautobahnen, ja.
Ja, die Datenautobahn wird Wirklichkeit,
nämlich äh sie wird es sie wird angegliedert dem Ministerium für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur. Einen Tag lang gefeiert als neuer Internetminister.
Vehement abgestritten wird.
Nicht er selber, oder? Also ähm.
Ich gar nicht.
Vehement abgestritten hat es dann am Ende Sigmar Gabriel aber doch kurz zurück. Alexander Dobrindt. Alexander Dobrindt,
ist der Minister für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur, also Autobahn,
Maut und Datenautobahnen. Das äh wird Alexander Dobrindt machen. Äh in der FAZ äh kommentiert mit den Worten bislang nicht als Internetkenner aufgefallen. Ich denke, das ist äh tatsächlich so,
Und am bekanntesten für seine Aussage, diejenigen, die gestern gegen Kernenergie,
heute gegen Stuttgart einundzwanzig demonstrieren agitieren, die müssen sich dann auch nicht wundern, wenn sie übermorgen irgendwann ein Minarett im Garten stehen.
Das wusste ich. Gibt's jetzt.
Das wusste ich übrigens gar nicht mehr. Äh vielen Dank an der Stelle an Peter Pixer, der mir das Zitat dann noch äh schnellst äh wieder ins Gedächtnis ruft, rief.
Ist ja schön. Gibt's die jetzt gibt's die jetzt.
Mehr, der hat noch mehr drauf, der hat noch mehr drauf.
Ja, gibt's jetzt so Minarette für den Garten jetzt bei Opi oder was? Zum Mitnehmen oder was?
Nee, dauert noch ein bisschen. Müssen, müssen erstmal ein bisschen gegen Stuttgart einundzwanzig und Atomkraft demonstrieren.
Ach so, ja gut.
Obacht, Die Grünen sind keine Partei, sondern der politische Arm von Krawallmachern, Steinwerfern und Brandstiftern,
auch schön.
Hm, so sieht man so mit seinen Freunden in Hessen aus und äh in Verbindung setzen und dann nochmal schnell die Warnung aussprechen, weil da äh steht ja nun die schwarz-grüne äh Koalition, willst du jetzt hier gegen jeden neuen äh Minister äh äh wettern und alte Sachen aus?
An, ich habe doch einfach nur mal so sein, so grob, dass man so so ein so ein Zitat spricht auch Bände.
Ja.
Er hat dann allerdings so, muss man auch sagen, ähm.
Ähm immer schön. Ja.
Dorothee Bär äh eine.
Verkehrsministerium. Ist sie? Ah ja, okay.
Staatssekretärin Dorothee Bär und,
das ist ja eine, die jetzt eher so in der CDU, also auf der CDU-Skale, auf der
Auf der CDU eine äh progressive äh Netzpolitikerin ist. Also man darf da durchaus hoffen. Ähm was ein Infrastrukturausbau äh angeht, muss man sich dann grundsätzlich nochmal fragen,
was ja auch schon vorher gesagt wurde zum Koalitionsvertrag von jenen Konzernen, die diese Infrastruktur dann unterhalten äh und verkaufen wollen an die Bürger,
dass sie sagten, ja wie ähm hat er denn auch ein Budget, was er uns irgendwie in den Arsch schieben kann, damit wir das auch machen? Weil grundsätzlich am Ausbau sind wir ja auch interessiert. Die Frage ist ja, äh wie wir ähm,
Das finanziert bekommen oder wie wir das so finanziert bekommen, dass wir trotzdem noch ähm,
international wettbewerbsfähig bleiben. Ich denke mal so könnte man das positiv ausdrücken.
Ja, ich finde da mal ganz positiv rangehen. Ich meine, vielleicht ist einfach grundsätzlich diese Kompetenzansammlung im Verkehrsministerium auch gar nicht mal so falsch
aber da kenne ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt mit den Kompetenzen und tatsächlichen Zuständigkeiten dieses Ministeriums zu wenig aus, aber die Idee äh,
quasi in der Verkehrswegeplanung auch eine digitale Verkehrswegeplanung zu verankern,
Die finde ich jetzt erstmal gar nicht so abwegig, weil das ist schon so der Ort, wo man im Prinzip.
Sich mit dem richtigen Medium, nämlich den Wegen äh.
Ist schon okay, ist schon okay.
Ja also man könnte da vielleicht tatsächlich auch äh in die richtige Richtung äh sich bewegen. Könnte man. Ob das stattfindet.
Er hat den Deutschen das schnellste und intelligenteste Netz der Welt versprochen. Ich frage mich, warum wir jetzt im Netz auf einmal Intelligenz haben wollen. Das muss irgendwie so eine NSA-Idee sein.
Intelligence.
Wir wollen als Deutsche und als Europäer digitale Souveränität zurückgewinnen,
und sogar ein kleines Lippenbekenntnis zu Netzneutralität bei ihm abzuringen. Auch hier, ich verurteile da niemanden vor, ich bin gespannt, äh was wir da sehen können mit dieser.
Möchte gerne schnelle Intelligence haben, ja?
Hat er da auf jeden Fall mal jemanden an der Hand, der kompetent ist
Ja, also ich bin der rote Beer ist auch mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber sie ist wenigstens nicht offensichtlich inkompetent, äh wie es wie es ihr Vorgesetzter dann da sein wird.
Aber als dann das große äh Deutschland hat einen Internetminister, er heißt Dobrindt, das war ja so das, das äh Feuerchen, was dann einen Tag lang da abgebrannt wurde,
meldete sich natürlich sofort der neue Wirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel und sagte äh Freunde, äh die digitale Agenda ist natürlich in meinem äh Resort angesiedelt, der ähm,
Du Print ist nur für das äh für die Infrastruktur zuständig. Das heißt, er sieht sich eigentlich äh als den neuen Internetminister. Auch da erinnern wir uns äh an seine äh eingehende Rede, von den Lebensrealitäten der Menschen, in denen das Internet keine Rolle spielt,
Ex-Justizministerin meine Güte.
Brigitte Zypries ist seine äh Staatssekretärin. Ähm sind wir mal gespannt, was was wir da erwarten dürfen von Sigmar Gabriel.
Sehr schön fand ich diese Schlagzeile im Spiegel. Zoff ums digitale Gabriel drosselt Minister Dobrindt. Die Drossel ist echt angekommen.
Sehr schön. Ähm.
Thomas de Maizire, verlässt das ähm Verteidigungsministerium, geht zurück ins Innenministerium, wo er ja schon mal war, wenn ich mich nicht täusche und ähm.
Da kommt er her, sozusagen. Da musste er kurz zur Seite äh äh springen wegen dir dein Lieblingsminister,
und äh jetzt äh bevor er da komplett zerschossen wird auf dem Schützenplatz, so, das ist ja.
Drohnen zum Opfer.
Wer genau äh den Eurohawks und wie sie alle heißen, da würde er dann schnell mal wieder an so einen Punkt gebracht, wo er meiner Meinung nach auch noch,
erträglichste ist. Also äh ja,
immer noch an das grundsätzlich problematisch, aber äh de Maizire ist zumindest jemand, der den Eindruck macht, dass es A eben schon auch irgendwie,
ums Land geht, ja? Und der irgendwie in der Lage ist, ganze Sätze zu sprechen.
Ich erinnere mich, dass ähm vor einiger Zeit dann auch im CCC Jahresrückblick der Frank sich einmal vorsichtig zu ihm geäußert hat und gesagt hat, dass der Mann zumindest irgendwie nicht,
blöd ist und Sachen versteht. Das hatte man ja bei einigen vorhergehenden Innenministern nicht immer den Eindruck, ähm allerdings ähm,
soll der Unterbau, den er jetzt da vorfindet in seinem Innenministerium, nicht äh besonders äh progressiv sein. Das heißt, die die äh Personen, die an seinem.
Ministerium, na ja.
Werden da weiter das alte Lied singen. Das Ministerium sieht sich dann zuständig für IT-Sicherheit, E-Government, et cetera,
ähm werden wir also sehen, was was da passiert. Es ist zumindest nicht ähm,
Ist jetzt keine besonders schlechte Nachricht, ja.
Ähm Justizminister Heiko Maas, den haben wir jetzt schon zweimal äh gewürdigt in seiner kurzen äh Amtszeit. Der hat sich als Staatssekretär
Also da ist ja dann so der Verbraucherschutz angesiedelt, was ja dann für uns als als äh Internet äh Heinis auch nochmal eine Rolle spielt.
Also neuerdings ist er dort angesiedelt.
Genau und da hat er sich den Staatssekretär Gerd Bilen aus dem Vorstand der des Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverbandes hingeholt, sicherlich auch keine,
allzu schlechte Wahl und lässt auch erstmal hoffen, wenn der Gerd Billen da weiter seine Linie fährt, dann kann man davon Justizministerium,
kann man da hoffen. Also es ist nicht so schlimm wie ich ursprünglich gedacht habe als klar war Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger.
Geht weg.
Verlässt die Bühne.
Ja, ist sehr interessant, dass der Verbraucherschutz jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, mit der Justizfrage mehr verbunden wird und nicht so sehr mit der Ernährungsfrage, wie das ja vorher der Fall war, als,
das ursprüngliche einmal eingeführt wurde, wurde es ja dem Umweltministerium zuge äh dem Landwirtschaftsministerium äh sind auch gleich.
Elf, Ilseeeigner.
Dein vorher die grüne ähm ja die unvergessliche, grüne.
Unvergessliche Grüne.
Politikerin.
Claudia kann ja nur Claudia Roth sein, aber die weiß nicht.
Die andere an.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich du hast das Google ist da. Ich rede einfach.
Ja ich.
Ich red weiter von Sachen, von dem wir eine Ahnung haben. Ähm,
Genau, der Verbraucherschutz war ja früher an dem äh Bundesministerium für Ernährung, Landwirtschaft und Verbraucherschutz und ist jetzt dem äh Justizministerium äh zugeordnet worden,
Wen haben wir denn noch? Ah ja, Peter Altmaier? Äh wird Kanzleramtsminister?
Ja, eine sehr interessante Personalie.
Und äh im im Internet ja vor allem dadurch bekannt, dass er twittert.
Renate Künast.
Unvergessliche Grüne.
Offensichtlich doch nicht, aber ich meine, es ist schon eine der profilierteren äh.
Sie schießt noch.
Grünen Partei. Ja, aber sie war die erste, die sozusagen dieses am Verbraucherschutz äh überhaupt erstmal ins Leben gerufen hat. Also vorher war das ja sozusagen so nicht da und dann ging's halt da über Seehofer, Eigner et cetera.
Wer war nochmal die unvergessliche? Hilf mir,
Ähm und dann gibt's natürlich noch ähm also einen einer, der jetzt weg ist, leider, ne, der ehemalige Kanzleramtschef Ronald Puffala,
Der ist jetzt weg. Der geht jetzt irgendwie in den Vorstand der Bahn, äh wobei da natürlich jetzt äh selbst Angela Merkel gesagt hat, dass das ja wohl ein bisschen,
gewisse geschmacklos war, dass irgendwie so im nahtlosen Anschluss zu machen und sich noch nicht mal irgendwie die drei bis sechs Monate ähm,
Pause zu gönnen, um den Anschein zu erwecken, dass das nicht von vorne herein klar gewesen wäre, ja. Äh das ist also äh da zeigt der Mann mal wieder Fingerspitzengefühl und warum er.
Weil er derjenige ist, der auch am lautesten geschrien hat, als seiner Zeit Schröder zu der Pipeline abgemarschiert ist und genau das gefordert hat, ja? Also das ist wirklich äh der Mann ist äh.
Ja ja, der Mann ist äh gut. Der kricht halt gut, der macht das super. Ähm.
Diese diese Nummer, diese,
Beendung der Affäre, ja. Der NSA-Affäre, das ist eben schon ganz schön auf die Füße gefallen. Das merkt man so. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so der Grund war, dass er gegangen ist, ob er sowieso gehen wollte, Pipapo, aber äh das wird ja so schnell nie los.
Ich find's interessant, weil wir hatten ja ähm,
Wir haben ja genau über diese Personalie haben wir mal hier in einer Sendung spekuliert. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche das war. Äh wo ich dann auch meinte, so entweder muss man den weg befördern oder man sagt, ist auch gut gelaufen.
Offensichtlich lag ich da falsch, weil ich ja so durchaus die die ähm Möglichkeit im Raum sah, dass er äh dafür belohnt wird und ihm gesagt wird, okay Alter.
Sehr gut gemacht.
Durchziehen so. Hast du gut gemacht. Ähm.
War wohl doch nicht so gut.
So, dann haben wir aber, glaube ich, auch, ja, Hans-Peter Friedrich äh ins äh Ministerium für Ernährung und Landwirtschaft. Da ist er, glaube ich, aus seiner Wählerschicht einfach sehr viel näher. Ähm.
Gewahnt wird davor, weil ja alle sagten, okay super, dass das Internet feiert, dass äh Friedrich irgendwie ausm
die Einschläge von Friedrich irgendwie wieder weiter von weiter weg erklingen. Ähm es wird davor gewarnt, dass das Landwirtschaftsministerium großen Einfluss auf dieses,
Partnership und,
Hat und also diese ganzen ich bin da noch nicht äh Firmen, was die neuen äh Freihandelsabkommen,
äh auf der Agenda angeht. Da werden wir uns in einer der kommenden Sendung dann mal detailliert mit auseinandersetzen, zumal da bis jetzt relativ wenig Informationen bekannt sind, bis auf das, was Wiki Leaks äh vor kurzem dann äh veröffentlicht hatte.
Also Friedrich eventuell erstmal aus der aus der Zone raus, wo er großen Schaden anrichten kann, wenn wir Pech haben, aber auch nicht.
Ähm.
Hatten wir übrigens in Lokbuch Netzpolitik fünfundsiebzig. Blick in die Schüssel.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas, was Internet relevant ist? Nein.
Nö, aber es reicht ja auch, ne? Also wir haben ja hier schon ein nachhaltiges Sendungsprogramm äh abgeliefert.
Das sind jetzt genau das sind jetzt so denke ich mal die äh die Minister, die dann netzpolitisch uns in den nächsten Jahren beschäftigen werden, wenn sie nicht früher über irgendwelche Affären,
den Posten räumen müssen.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Dann wurde äh laut diskutiert ähm aber auch nur zwei Tage und äh das habe ich dann auch leider ein bisschen aus den Augen verloren. Der Hauptausschuss für Internet und digitale Agenda, AIDA.
Den soll es geben und da werden dann sollen dann so die Gesetzesvorhaben zur Digitalisierung äh diskutiert werden,
Ähm also da sollen sich dann auch die Beteiligten Ministerien äh drin äh treffen. Ich bin mal gespannt, äh ob und wie der zustande kommt. Da gab's dann große Kritik am
von irgendwie Konstantin von Notz und so. Ich bin aber ganz ehrlich, da kann ich wenig zu sagen, weil ich.
Ich freue mich, welchen welchen Politikbereich, in welchen Ministerien das dann im Wesentlichen so.
Na, das wären dann wahrscheinlich eher die Ministerien, die wir jetzt gerade so besprochen haben mit,
Nee, also eher äh Tobrint, äh äh Autobahn und Datenautobahn. Gabriel Wirtschaft
Innenministerium, Thomas de Maizire, Justizministerium Heiko Maas, das wäre jetzt so die, die ich
unmittelbar mit Internet in Verbindung sehen würde und die ich dann da entsprechend in dem Hauptausschuss vertreten sehen würde, wobei ich jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade einen vergessen habe, der wird dann in den Kommentaren nachgereicht.
Ja, aber das ist der ist ja noch nicht gegründet, ne? Das ist jetzt nur angekündigt worden, dass er gegründet wird.
Ja, so habe ich das verstanden.
Ja, ich habe da auch noch nichts gehört. Also es gibt hier so auch keinen Vorsitzenden et cetera. Den wird wahrscheinlich die CDU äh stellen, nehme ich mal an.
Na weiß ich nicht, vielleicht schafft's ja auch Herr Gabriel, wenn er wirklich der super Internet Digitalminister wird, sich da nochmal irgendwie vorzudrängeln, wir werden's sehen.
Wir werden's sehen. Also es steht zur Debatte und ähm ich bin dann mal gespannt. Ich kann da jetzt leider auch wenig ähm.
Wenig zu sagen,
bis jetzt. Wenn er, wenn er dann gründet, wenn er sich dann konstituiert, wenn wir uns die Besetzung dann nochmal genauer anschauen. Vielleicht hat er sich auch schon konstituiert und wir haben's einfach verpennt.
Noch ein paar Zitate aus der Mottenkiste herausholen.
Dann habe ich noch so ein bisschen so zum Ende der Sendung ein äh eine Sammlung an an bisschen Boulevard.
Noch mehr Boulevard.
Ja ja also so die Sachen, die nicht wirklich relevant sind, aber was ich sehr schön fand, es gibt ähm Angela Merkel hat sich ja in einem äh persönlichen Gespräch mit Obama geäußert und aus diesem Gespräch sind zwei Zitate überliefert,
ähm das Erste ist, dass sie sich beklagt hat, das was die NSA mache, wäre ja wie die Stasi. Ähm,
bezog sich damit auf das Abhören ihres Telefons und auf die Massenüberwachung,
von deutschen Bürgern ja also immerhin, das scheint sie erkannt zu haben und dann wird ihr von der New York Times äh in den Mund gelegt ähm,
NSA offensichtlich ja nicht mit privaten Informationen trauen könnte, weil,
zugelassen hat, dass der die da rausträgt.
Das hat Merkel gesagt.
Das äh zitiert die New York Times. Also.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob das jetzt also äh so zitiert's auf jeden Fall die New York Times, fand ich mal,
Wenn sie nach dem, das ist ja hier wie die Stasi mal den Mund gehalten hätte, aber dann zu sagen so, ey, Alter, ihr habt da Whistleblower Problem. So, ich kann mir doch nicht trauen. Das finde ich schon echt.
Wenn ihr mal die Backen besser zusammenhalten würdet, dann könntet ihr euch auch weiterhin mit Scheiße vollstopfen. Na, so.
So, das ist schon, das ist schon echt scharf.
Na ja, der Bulle war.
Boulevard. Und dann äh ich weiß nicht,
Ich wollte eigentlich noch äh kurz was dazu sagen, weil das ja auch in der Sondersendung vom äh dreißig C drei dann nochmal kurz angesprochen wurde, dass ich mir den äh Assange-Talk äh angeschaut habe. Ähm,
Beim dreißig C3,
Der großspurig angekündigte Assange-Talk. Von vielen Jahren äh kritisiert dafür, äh dass man ja schließlich andere Helden einladen könnte, zum Beispiel Jacob Apple bauen,
das waren dann die Personen, die äh sich in ihrer Aufregung noch nicht einmal die Zeit genommen haben, in den Fahrplan zu schauen, denn dieser Vortrag war zusammen mit Jacob Applebaum
eingereicht worden wurde zusammen mit Jacob Apple Warm gehalten
und hatte als äh Sondergast die nicht angekündigt war, auch noch äh Sarah Harrison mit dabei,
Die WikiLeaks-Anwältin, die ihren maßgeblichen Beitrag dazu geleistet hat, dass sich jetzt in Russland aufhält und noch,
Kopf, der mit seinem Rumpf verbunden ist, hat.
Anwältin ist sie auch. Ist ja nicht primär als Journalistin. Nee, das ist gemacht. Ach so. Ähm ich hab's verwechselt.
Nee, das ist jemand anders. Ähm oder ich habe das jetzt krass verwechselt, aber sie war auf jeden Fall die Begleiterin von äh Edward Snowden. Ähm und ist da bis jetzt sehr wenig mit,
Okay, dann habe ich das.
Heißt es hier, also.
Ah okay, also ich weiß, dass sie sein juristischer Beistand war, aber ich sie ist oft, okay, sie ist keine offizielle Anwältin.
Vermutlich nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall ihr Spezialgebiet.
Sie war dann auch noch mit auf der Bühne.
Hat sich nochmal ein bisschen Applaus eingefangen.
Ja, sie hat vor allem erstmal ein Statement verlesen, ähm indem sie ihre eigene Situation da auch mal thematisiert hat und äh Kritik an an der äh Politik der USA äh geübt hat, denke ich, war sehr
sehr hörenswert, wenn auch nichts Neues dabei, ihren Applaus hat sie sich da, denke ich, redlich verdient.
Nicht nur in den USA, vor allem an ihrem Heimatland, also an UK und angekündigt, dass sie da halt jetzt auch nicht hinfährt, würde ich bemerkenswert. Also Jake Apple-Baum hängt in Berlin fest.
Nicht in die USA reisen, weil er einfach nicht mehr das Vertrauen hat dort wie ein äh ja Bürger erster Klasse behandelt zu werden, sagen wir es mal so und äh hier geht's offensichtlich mit Britannien ähnlich.
Mehrere, die gerade in Berlin rum.
Also es ist wirklich eine interessante Ansammlung.
Sie sich ausgerechnet hier sicher fühlen, ist aber, glaube ich, auch Abitrea. Ich glaube, die fühlen sich einfach nur hier wohl. Ähm.
Ja gut, das äh mag auch eine Rolle spielen so, aber es gibt schlechtere Orte, wo man sein kann. Definitiv.
Und dann äh war ja groß angekündigt worden, dass äh man irgendwie nicht das CCC da einem Vergewaltiger eine Bühne bietet und das werde man nicht zulassen. Ähm das haben sich dann auch offensichtlich Personen dazu entschieden, das nicht zuzulassen und die Methode
die sie dazu gewählt haben war nicht etwa irgendwie sag ich mal ein Protest in diesem Vortragsraum zu tragen wie ich es redlich und interessant gefunden hätte
ja
äh sondern man hat sich dazu entschlossen, den gesamten Raum äh vom Internet zu trennen, in dem man irgendwie mehrmals ungünstig übers Kabel äh stolperte, wodurch dann eben die Verbindung zu Julien Assange äh äh getrennt wurde.
Und ähm habe da jetzt irgendwie,
so mal drüber nachgedacht, ich hätte es natürlich persönlich äh schöner gefunden, wenn man da eine Form des Protestes gewählt hätte, die ähm auch eine Aussage transportiert,
und nicht einfach nur ähm das Internet abschaltet,
Und ich muss sagen, dass ich nicht ganz verstehe oder was was mich wirklich beschäftigt ist, wie ein Mensch aufn ähm also das ist offensichtlich Menschen gibt, die den CCC-Kongress besuchen,
Und das für eine akzeptable Handlung halten, dreieinhalbtausend Leute vom Internet zu trennen.
Um damit jemand anderes am Sprechen zu hindern. Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt doch überrascht. Das äh habe ich nicht für also,
habe ich nicht für denkbar gehalten, dass äh jemand das tun würde.
Ich bin mit der Aktion auch überhaupt nicht glücklich gewesen,
sagen wir mal äh letztlich nur ein kleiner äh eine kleine äh Aktion letztlich geblieben im Vergleich zu dem, was insgesamt auf dieser ganzen Veranstaltung äh von vielen geleistet wurde und geschaffen wurde.
Sich ja auch niemand von diesen Vögeln irgendwie den Spaß verderben lassen. Also.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch, ich meine, man kann äh Assange, man kann zu ihm stehen, wie man will. Ja, aber in dem Moment, wo man ihn da äh ins Programm gerufen hat und ihm die Gelegenheit gibt, da irgendwie ein Statement abzugeben, dann soll man sich irgendwie mit seinen Statements auseinandersetzen.
Und das gab ja zumindest noch ein paar, mit denen man sich dann auch sehr wohl auseinandersetzen kann und auch da sehe ich äh einige Ansätze,
zur Kritik, ja? Zu berechtigten Kritik.
Wunderbar.
Aber Leute äh einfach nicht äh reden zu lassen, ist an der Stelle halt einfach feige und doof.
Ja, also da hätte ich, da bin ich enttäuscht, Jungs. Da hätte ich äh und Mädels, da hätte ich mehr erwartet. Da äh wurden ja auch großspurig äh äh wilde Aktionen angekündigt, aber ähm na ja.
Gut, was jetzt die Motivation im Einzelnen war, wissen wir nicht. Ja, also weder aus welchem Lager, aus welchem Grunde soll das kommt? Äh ist nicht nur aus einem,
nicht nur über ein einziges Thema in der Kritik so, ja? Also,
Die Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe stehen da für mich noch auch relativ weit aus und das ist halt einfach eher auch eine eine Frage äh wie man sich da äh wie man die Szene überhaupt anspricht.
Und äh die These, man solle jetzt, ich meine, in der in den Medien ist es dann so berichtet worden als habe die Leute aufgerufen, äh die CIA einzutreten und.
Hat er gesagt.
Hat das wirklich wörtlich genau so gesagt. Äh okay, war ich mir jetzt nicht mehr so ganz sicher, ob's nur ähm überflogen den äh Vortrag oder zumindest nicht ausreichend gut zugehört, ähm weil's ja auch nicht durchgängig verständlich war,
Ja, dass ähm ja auf einem Kongress, wo äh am Ende äh alle nochmal aufgefordert werden, sich äh von solchen Organisationen möglichst weit fernzuhalten,
passte das auch nicht.
Er hat halt gesagt, ja äh früher haben wir gesagt, geht da nicht rein. Äh jetzt sage ich, geht rein, infiltriert diese Organisation und tragt die Sachen raus. Es ist äh eine eine äh eine These, die äh man schon so aufstellen kann. Wenn man sagt, okay.
Wenn ihr eh schon drin seid, das ist was anderes als geht rein, ja?
Der Marsch durch die Institution,
Ähm ja, also das das nur das kann man ja auch am am Rande so nennen. Ich fand, ich fand's wirklich erstaunlich, dass dass Menschen sich ernsthaft zum Abschalten des Netze, als als Protestform,
Äh da äh entscheiden.
Gut, jetzt machen wir aber hier mal den Deckel drauf. Äh.
Ich wollte euch nicht vielleicht noch was sagen.
Aber weitere Herausforderungen warten auf äh dich und auf mich.
Okay.
Unsere zwei Stunden zum Auftakt auch voll gemacht.
Super, haben wir einen schönen langen.
Einstiegspodcast. Kommen wir erstmal wieder im Monat einen Monat Pause machen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nee, das war ich nie wieder. Ich bin heute Morgen irgendwie um sieben Uhr aufgestanden, um den ganzen Kram zusammen zu tragen und wahrscheinlich hagelt's jetzt Kommentare, weil ich irgendwie so das Event äh der der vier Wochen oder des Jahres irgendwie übersehen habe. Ja nee, wir machen ja jetzt wieder schön regelmäßig.
Ja und ich glaube, dieser Kongress wird noch äh lange nachwirken auf alle Beteiligten und auch auf die Unbeteiligten. So, wir sagen tschüss. Tschau, tschau. Bis bald.